All right. What's up y'all? As always,
welcome to you wherever you're at.
YouTube, Facebook, Rumble, uh anywhere
else that this may be somewhere.
Grateful for you all. Hope everyone is
having a blessed evening.
Tonight, we're going to be opening the
floor up for any SDAs. I say that again.
SDAs, please, if you're not an
Adventist,
refrain from joining. Please only engage
in the chat um because the floor will be
open for them to change our mind
regarding the Jesus and gospel of
Adventism being false.
Last week on Facebook, to kick things
off here for us, I got tagged in a
thread of comments. The notification was
from a friend who was commenting on uh
someone else's post that I'm I'm not
friends with. And the comment asked if
I'd be willing to engage the primary
person that was posting, I think his
name was Brian, um regarding the
Adventist Gospel. So, I scrolled up to
the top of the comment thread. There was
like 20 some odd comments at this point
to see what the primary comment was um
about that the the tag was in. and it
had a link to tonight's stream in it.
So, I responded to the friend that
tagged me and said, "Yep, anytime, any
SDA, always ready to talk about cardinal
foundational doctrines of what really
matters about the faith, um, life or
death issues as obviously that's why I'm
doing this stream is to engage with
SDAs." Well, an SDA pastor by the name
of Jason Neely responded and we engaged
in some back and forth where we got to
see the standard character attack that
deals with none of the substance that is
presented. The charge was made that I'm
an angry person. I have a bad spirit. I
didn't leave Adventism over theology.
All of these standard assertions. My
response is always the same. Come have a
discussion then, sir. if I didn't
actually leave for the reasons I said,
which is the two topics primarily that
we're talking about tonight. Um, come
have a discussion and let's see who has
and hasn't done their homework. I was
told I only do this to destroy people. I
only want to debate. This is also false.
So, instead of actually dealing with the
proposition put forth, this Adventist
pastor had to do the standard fair
character attack. The focus had to
become about me, my personality, etc.,
and not on the substance of what was
presented. The Adventist Church claims
to be a beacon of light to the rest of
the world with a present truth message
that everyone needs to hear, accept, and
believe before it's too late. So,
tonight is your opportunity to share
that message and discuss um discuss it
if you're an Adventist. Don't resort to
the silly character attacks. We're we're
doing this to meaningfully engage. And
doing that does not lead to any sort of
actual engagement. character attack plan
is employed to distract away from the
substance of what's being said and it's
a cheap trick so let's not utilize it
cool um it doesn't actually do anything
because I have been very clear from the
outset we have a playlist dedicated to
this on the channel two playlists
regarding Jesus and the gospel we've
done I don't even know how many hours of
discussion on this at this point the
Adventist church has a false god and a
false gospel the Adventist Jesus is
actually an idol a violation of the
first commandment Adventist.
But that's why this platform exists.
It's an educational and evangelistic
outlet because we believe Adventists
need the true gospel and the true Christ
because a false God and a false gospel,
as we're about to see, cannot save you.
This is the core of the Christian faith.
Who is God? What is the gospel? I don't
care about your belief in hell. I don't
care about your belief in diet. I don't
care about your belief in the Sabbath. I
don't care about any of these tertiary
things because if you have the wrong God
and the wrong gospel, you can go to hell
being a vegetarian. You can go to hell
going to church on Saturday. None of
that stuff is going to save you. The
gospel is the power of God into
salvation. This is the core and heart of
the Christian faith. This is the
foundation. So that is where I start
with anybody regardless of if it's an
Adventist or not because that's the
core. And it's only the true Christ who
saves and the true gospel that is the
power of God into salvation. Simply
using the words gospel and Jesus are not
specific enough. What do you believe
about those things? What are those
things? Who are those? Who is that?
Who's Jesus? That same pastor I saw on
his on his Facebook wall because he told
me to check out his sermon that was
streaming on his channel that day. This
was before he got up to preach. He's
arguing with me on on Facebook. Um so I
go on his page and he says less the
something about the something to the
effect of we need to be doing less
theology, more about Jesus. Thinking to
myself, these pathy sayings, man, that
who's Jesus? You have to engage in
theology to to even talk about Jesus.
Who are we talking about? and Jason,
that's where the rubber meets the road.
That's that's why the the interaction
was so ironic. It's like, man, we go
back and forth, go back and forth, go
back and forth for you to finally then
say, well, I could be wrong about my
theology, but uh I I I know the one who
who uh you know, changed my life
basically. And I'm thinking, okay, who
is that? Because in order to discuss
that, you have to talk about theology.
That's what theology is. It's the it's
the study of who God is. Well, who is
God? The just it's crazy. Um, but that's
what I'm hoping to discuss tonight. If
you're an Adventist, the link to join is
pinned in the chat, at least on YouTube.
I don't know about the other platforms.
You may have to uh come to to the
YouTube chat to get the link. Um, and
again, the floor will be open to
Adventists. Please, if you are not in
SDA, please refrain from joining and
engage from the chat. But to set the
groundwork for my assertions,
I want to look at two paricopies of
scripture followed by a handful of
quotes from Ellen White. Yes, Adventist
Ellen White quotes because she is the
highest interpretive authority in the
Adventist church. It doesn't matter what
others say, she's the highest authority.
She's who the SDA church calls divinely
inspired and she is who they say
corrects inaccurate interpretations of
scripture. So, she holds the scales. If
you think she's wrong, let's discuss it.
If you think what she's saying bib
saying is biblical, let's discuss it and
see if it's consistent with scripture.
I'm going to simply cite authoritative
sources in the Adventist church that we
are told by the SDA church are all
rooted in scripture. precious rays of
light shining through from the throne
room of God. They supposedly shed light
as the lesser light onto the greater
light to help us properly understand it.
So scripture first and then a number of
statements regarding the Adventist
gospel specifically how the SDA church
teaches you are made right with God
meaning reconciliation. Then we will
talk briefly about the doctrinal
additions not just the things uh like
reconciliation that they have wrongfully
defined and twisted. And then we will
look at the Jesus of Adventism. So,
first up, mentioned this earlier. We
talked about this before on the channel.
We've talked about it a lot. Going to
keep on beating this drum. What does
Paul tell us in Galatians 1? Why am I
beating this drum? Because notice what
Paul says here. I know the headings are
not inspired, but the headings are
typically speaking into the content that
we're about to read. No other gospel. No
other gospel. Let's see what Paul says.
Galatians 1 6-12.
Paul writing to the Galatians, I'm
astonished,
shocked, in awe, can't believe it that
you're so quickly deserting him who
called you in the grace of Christ and
are turning to a different gospel.
Not that there is another one, but there
are some who trouble you and want to
distort the gospel of Christ. So, halt
right there. There's only one gospel.
There isn't a different gospel. He says
there isn't another one.
And there are some that were creeping
into the churches at Galatia trying to
distort that gospel.
And if you keep reading into chapter
four and five, the one thing they were
trying to add, one thing. That's all it
was. One thing, circumcision,
he says, I hope that their hand slips
and they completely emasculate the
person that's doing the the
circumcision. That's how Paul felt about
this twisting. But he continues, "But
even if we or an angel or three angels
from heaven should preach to you a
gospel contrary to the one we preach to
you, let him be accursed." That means
damned.
If we or an angel, anyone else comes
along and they're preaching a gospel
contrary to the one the apostles
preached, let that person be damned.
This is a serious issue. You don't see
language like this about every single
doctrine in scripture. This is further
evidence that the gospel is not just
everything you theologically believe. It
is a specific message. And if it ain't
coming from the apostles, it isn't the
gospel because they received it. Well,
as we're about to see, verse 9, as we've
said before, so now I say again, if
anyone is preaching to you a gospel
contrary to the one you received, let
him be accursed. For am I now seeking
the approval of man or of God? Or am I
trying to please man? If I were still
trying to please man, I'd not be a
servant of Christ.
For I would have you know, brothers,
that the gospel that was preached by me
is not man's gospel.
For I did not receive it from any man,
nor was I taught it, but I received it
through a revelation of Jesus Christ.
So the one true gospel came from Jesus
Christ. It was revealed to the apostles
that was then inscripturated for us
through forms of letters etc. which were
then
sent out to these churches at least the
epistles
and the Holy Spirit guiding his church
to recognize that which is scripture
compiled together for us the gospel
message which can be found in scripture.
There is only one gospel, not two.
There's not a full full gospel and a
truncated gospel or some of these other
terms that I've heard people like
Herbert Douglas and other scholars in
the SDA church try to kind of say, well,
you know, we're not we're not saying
that other people aren't preaching the
gospel. It's just that it's not the
fullness of the gospel. Nah, doesn't cut
it. Nope. There is no it's either all or
nothing. This is a pass fail. Okay. Now,
he says the same thing to the churches
in Corinth. He's writing up the second
time after he gets report back. If you
start back at the beginning of the
epistle, he gets report back after
sending the first letter
and he's basically
saying, "It's good to hear some of these
things, but you're still struggling in
some of these other areas." So, what
does he tell him here? So, in chapter
11,
he has a concern for them. He says,
quote, I wish you would bear with me a
little fool in a little foolishness. Do
bear with me for I feel a divine
jealousy for you since I betrothed you
to one husband to present you as a pure
virgin to Christ.
Paul had great love for this local body
and desired to see them growing in the
grace and mercy of Christ, their
knowledge and understanding of Christ.
But now he starts with the concern.
Everybody loves a good butt.
No pun intended there by the way.
But I am afraid that as the serpent
deceived Eve by his cunning,
your thoughts will be led astray from a
sincere and pure devotion to Christ. So
he longs for that for them, but he has
concern that that's going to be
negatively impacted.
That their thoughts will be led astray.
Their thoughts, meditate on that, folks,
their thoughts will be led astray.
Starts in the mind. It's what James
tells us, too.
starts in the mind and then it works
itself out into behavior and those types
of things. So what is he he worried
about creeping into their thoughts and
them accepting? Verse four, for if
someone comes and proclaims another
Jesus than the one we proclaimed, or if
you receive a different spirit from the
one you received, or if you accept a
different gospel from the one you
accepted, you put up with it readily
enough. Paul's concern was that they in
the process of seeking to grow in their
knowledge and understanding of the Lord
Jesus would be swooned away by a
different gospel, a different Christ,
and a different spirit that they would
entertain these things. So the point is
is that you can have false gospels.
You can have false Christs.
Simply saying the name is not enough.
You have to have certain details about
it or him
to have the real deal.
So that's why this is the primary focus
on this channel. Not that we don't
discuss other things etc. But this is
the foundation. This is the hill that
the flag is planted in.
So with that in mind,
let's now look at a couple quotes. Okay,
we're going to start with
the Gospel of Adventism. And again,
these quotes, we're going to focus on
the reconciliation aspect of how this
church has a false understanding of
reconciliation, which is a damnable
issue. Yes, a damnable issue.
So, we're going to start with looking at
some of those.
Notice what she says here.
First quote, Spirit of Prophecy, Volume
1, page 49. The code is down there at
the bottom, folks, in red. If you want
to go to egwritings.org,
org. You can type in that code right
there. 1 SP space 49.3. It'll take you
right to it. All the quotes tonight. And
we're not going to look at a ton, but
for those that want to notice what she
says. Quote, "Through Christ, a door of
hope was opened that man,
notwithstanding his great sin, should
not be under the absolute control of
Satan.
Faith in the merits of the Son of God
would be would so elevate man that he
could resist the devices of Satan.
Probation would be granted him in which
through a life of repentance and faith
in the atonement of the son of God, he
might be redeemed from his transgression
of the father's law and thus be elevated
to a position where his efforts to keep
his law could be accepted. Close quote.
So how is a person saved according to
this? This is like a sotiological
um overview in a sense and we're going
to build on this with getting a fuller
picture here in a moment. But she says
by faith in Christ merits Adventist you
love to point to this and say no no no
it's Christ merits it's Christ's merits.
Yeah that that's not the thing that
we're going to take umbrage with. By
faith in Christ merits you're then
elevated to a position where you can now
resist Satan. Okay that that's that's
great. There's a change that happens
within people. We could get into talking
about regeneration and and what all that
looks like,
but you're put on a period of probation
by your repentance and faith in the work
of Jesus. And this elevated state makes
it to where your efforts to keep the law
can be accepted.
Wrong.
False. You know what I have to say to
that? Did he SAY THAT? DID HE SAY THAT?
Just change it after she. No, like I
said, it is true that believers are
freed from their slavery to sin. Being
born again produces a change in an
individual and they're now um impacted
by new desires, godly desires, seeking
to please God with their life, something
they the lost do not experience.
However, the idea that you are elevated
to a position where your lawkeeping can
be accepted is flatout false. It is
Jesus's perfect lawkeeping by his active
and passive obedience that is then given
to a person
and they are seen as having kept the law
perfectly. Philippians 3:8 and9.
But let's fill out the picture a little
bit more.
Second quote, Testimonies for the
Church, volume 4, page 27.
Quote, faith is not certainty of
knowledge. It is the substance of things
hoped for, the evidence of things not
seen. quoting Hebrews. To obey the
commandments of God is the only way to
obtain his favor. Close quote.
[Music]
No. Obedience to the Ten Commandments is
not the only way to obtain God's favor.
One obtains God's favor by believing the
gospel.
Paul explains in Galatians 3:10-14
that the righteous shall live by faith.
And unless one is doing everything in
the law perfectly, they are under a
curse. No matter how much you seek to
keep the Ten Commandments,
you break it once, it's over.
Our faith is what earns favor because
faith is the vehicle by which Christ's
perfect righteousness is credited to us.
Again, Philippians 3:8:9. And it's only
by being quote in Christ, united to
Christ, that you can receive God's
favor. You enter into Christ by true and
saving faith.
The law is not based on faith. Galatians
3:12.
Christ became a curse for us to free us
from being under the law covenantally.
Galatians 3:13-14.
And one receives favor from God by
placing their faith in the person and
finished work of Jesus Christ for
sinners. And it's his perfect
righteousness that earns favor, his
perfect lawkeeping.
Now, that's not to say that Christians
do not seek to obey God.
but simply that your good works and
efforts do not earn favor. They are the
fruit of already having been are already
having God's favor by being in Christ.
And again, that happens by faith. Romans
3:22-23,
Romans 8 1-2, Ephesians 1 7-14.
It is the perfect work of Jesus on
behalf of believers alone that God looks
upon with favor.
Next quote.
looked at this one multiple times on the
channel. Testimonies for the Church,
Volume 4,
page 294.
Quote, "Man has defaced the image of God
in his soul by a corrupt life or sorry,
man who has defaced the image of God in
his soul by a corrupt life cannot by
mere human effort effect a radical
change in himself."
Okay. Yeah. He must accept the
provisions of the gospel. Okay. What are
those provisions? He must be reconciled
to God through obedience to his law and
faith in Jesus Christ.
His life from then forth must be
governed by a new principle. It's just
sandwiched right in there. Just the the
damnable heresy just sandwiched right in
there between, you know, generally
speaking true statements. Then we get
another one. Through repentance, faith,
and good works, he may perfect a
righteous character and claim through
the merits of Christ, of course, the
privileges of the sons of God. close
quote. Damnable heresy. No.
Yes, man must accept the gospel. That is
absolutely true. But notice what she
says. The provisions of the gospel are
reconciliation through one, obedience to
the law, and two, faith in Christ. And
that by uh repentance, faith, and good
works, you can perfect a righteous
character. And then at that point,
through Christ's merits, of course,
receive the privileges of being the the
a child of God.
No, it is a person's faith in the person
and work of Jesus. Romans 5 9-11, as
well as getting into the ministry of
reconciliation, 2 Corinthians 5.
But it is a person's faith in the person
and work of Jesus, which includes his
perfect obedience to the law,
Philippians 2:8, that reconciles a
person to God. Believers are given a
foreign alien righteousness in full, not
little spurts over time, as if a little
spurt of Jesus's righteousness is still
not enough. like you would be even be
able to dish it out in little tidbits.
No, believers are given a foreign alien
righteousness in full from God himself
when they believe. Again, Philippians
3:9. This places them in a position
before God where they are seen as if
they have indeed kept the law perfectly
when they have not. The picture could be
explained this way. Jesus is standing in
front of the believer and God the Father
sees him and his perfect life in place
of the believer. But in Adventist
theology, Jesus is standing off to the
side of you, cheering you on,
doing his best to help you, to get you
to a place where you need to be, where
you can be accepted.
But he's not in front of you as you're
covering.
This is what being in Christ entails,
folks. We've talked about this many
times on the channel, and we'll continue
to do so. Union with Christ. Being
united to Christ,
being united to him by faith. The New
Testament is replete with this phrase in
Christ and in him to refer to the status
of believers. I mean it is everywhere. 2
Corinthians 5:17-18, Romans 8 1-2, uh 1
Corinthians 1:30, Galatians 2:26-27,
Ephesians 1 3-6, 11-14, uh Galatians or
uh Ephesians 2:6
and Galatians 3:26-27 already says those
who are in Christ are present tense
children of God. We've already been
adopted, transferred from the kingdom of
darkness to the kingdom of light, been
made new creatures. We have peace with
God. Debt paid in full, already
reconciled to God. Have peace with God.
Romans 5:1, Romans 8:1. Like, no. It
It's not something where,
well, after you get to a certain place,
then you'll be seen as being able to be
adopted. Then you can be adopted at a
future at a future state. Nor is it well
yeah you you have been adopted but
Johnny based on your behavior dad may
disown you. No dad will chastise you
like a good parent does and a person who
has these desires when God chastises
them repents and corrects etc. But that
doesn't maintain your reconciliation or
keep you in the family etc. These are
all signs of fruit. These are not things
that are attached to the root. Obedience
to Jesus is a byproduct of already
having been reconciled and having peace
with God. Again, Romans 5:1, that's not
something believers do to maintain their
reconciliation or be seen uh as worthy
and as Ellen said, is being seen and
worthy of Christ's atoning benefits
eventually. No, believers are completely
secure in the person and work of Jesus
and their true heartfelt trust in him
and his saving grace. And this is the
problem with these, you know, man-
centered theologies that think God
somehow fails at saving people because
they're somehow able to thwart the
mighty work of Jesus and God's
miraculous work of regeneration and
making somebody a new creature in
Christ. There isn't going back after
that, folks. You aren't born again, then
unborn again to then possibly be born
again again. No, Jesus is a savior.
He He That means he saves people. He
doesn't just open the door like Ellen
said be earlier in that first quote and
now he's trying his best. No, he is a
perfect savior. He actually saves
people.
There's a very drastically different
idea going on here between synergism and
monergism.
One being a god- centered ideology.
The next quote,
Signs of the Times, July 31, 1901,
14 years before her death, toward the
end of her life. Quote, for the highest
good of his creatures, God has given a
perfect law, a law that demands perfect
obedience. Okay. Yep. The law does
demand perfect obedience. God compels no
one to obey this law. He leaves men free
to decide whether they will obey and
receive the reward of obedience or
disobey and receive the punishment of
transgression.
[Music]
Again, in utter distortion of the gospel
with subtle truth mixed in, confusing
categories. This is proof that the
Adventist church is not Protestant
because a foundational teaching to
Protestantism is a law gospel
distinction.
Again, the law is not a reconciliation
device. All of that is distinct to the
gospel. These two things are not the
same. They have different uses and
purposes. The law's purpose is not a
reconciliation tool.
But she's correct. Yes, God's law
demands perfect obedience. Absolutely.
But that means if you've ever broken it,
you're doomed. That's the standard. It
has no provisions for forgiveness. It
has no stipulations for it's do this and
you'll live, do that and you'll die.
There's no reconciliation. There's no
forgiveness. It is a legal covenant,
a law work covenant. The law does not
have escape hatches like that, which is
why God had to be the just and the
justifier, which we'll talk about in a
moment.
But that's the standard, perfect
obedience. It isn't perfect obedience
after you've tried a million times, but
you keep trying with the help of the
Holy Spirit to eventually get to a place
where you're sinlessly perfect and
keeping the law perfectly. Thus, you
have perfect obedience. No. Which is
what they teach.
It demands perfect obedience. We have to
get to this point where we're
demonstrating we can keep it to be shown
that we're can be trusted to enter into
the heaven and the new earth and not let
sin enter again. No, folks. It's not all
right, hurry up and get to a point where
you can demonstrate that you okay, now
you're keeping it perfectly. No,
you you you're dead in your sins, man.
Your only hope is in Jesus Christ by
being in Christ. And I really hope that
Adventists can can really I love talking
with Adventists who come to this
understanding of seeing this distinction
between the gospel and the law and that
yeah the law does have a proper use.
Yeah, the law like Paul says is holy,
righteous, and good, but it can be
lawfully uh wielded
or unlawfully. It can be unlawfully
wielded, which is what the Adventist
church is doing. The problem is not the
law. The problem is the Adventist church
is handling a weapon that they have zero
business handling, and they're just
creating a spiritual crime scene in the
souls of millions of people.
But this is why Ellen White and
Adventist theology has no concept of the
law gospel distinction. which again is
fundamental to Protestantism and that's
what they so desperately want to put out
the public image out there that they are
trying to align with that or we're in
line with that. No, Jesus kept the law
perfectly. We have not. He did what we
cannot do. He then imputes that to us
such that it is uh as if we have kept
the law perfectly when we haven't. And
that's how the demands of the law are
met yet people are still spared for
having broken it. Which, like I said,
that is what Romans 3:26 is talking
about when it talks about God being both
the just and the justifier. He's just by
punishing sin and did so by punishing
Jesus Christ, the son, who was actually
innocent.
And he did what we failed to do, what
what man failed to do.
So, he's the justifier because he then
spares those who are in Christ. He both
punishes sin and spares people who have
committed it. It is a God- centered
work, not part it's not part God and
part man doing his due diligence like
Ellen wrongfully asserts about Romans
3:26 on numerous occasions. She also
falsely associates salvation in this
quote with a reward.
No, salvation is a gift. Ephesians 2
8-10.
A reward is something you receive for
your efforts. A gift is something wholly
bestowed freely by the giver.
Last one.
for transitioning to statements about
the Adventist Jesus. A little bit of a
long one. Sons and daughters. Page 156.
Quote, "Will man take hold of divine
power and with the determination and
perseverance resist Satan?" Similar to
that first quote we looked at. As Christ
has given him example in his conflict
with the foe in the wilderness of
temptation. Halt.
Adventist. that the wilderness is not
something for you to look and see
yourself in.
This is again where man-c centered
theology and Adventism is not the only
group out there that's like this. It's
an anthropocentric system. It's
everything you read, you're how can I
read myself into this? How am I supposed
to see myself? You're not you're not
supposed to see Christ. The purpose of
the temptation of of Christ in the
wilderness is not to see, oh well, Jesus
was just a man like I was. So, he's
setting the example that, okay, yeah,
Satan's accusations of the great
controversy are false and and all this
stuff. The purpose of Jesus's temptation
was for him to do what the first Adam
failed to do. And as the second Adam, he
did everything the first Adam was
supposed to do and failed. But he he is
doing it perfectly. Even down to the
dominion mandate,
commanded to subdue all the earth. Well,
Adam failed to do that. Well, Christ is
doing that now as he rules and reigns
from heaven as the second Adam. And he
is all dominion, all authority in heaven
and on earth. Again, doing what the
first Adam failed to do. But she
continues, "God cannot save man against
his will from the power of Satan's
artififices.
Man must work with his human power aided
by the divine power of Christ to resist
and to conquer at any cost to himself.
In short, man must overcome as Christ
overcame.
And then through the victory that is his
privilege to gain by the all powerful
name of Jesus, he may become an heir of
God and joint heir with Jesus Christ.
This could not be the case if Christ
alone did all the overcoming. Man must
do his part. He must be victor in his
own on his own account through the
strength and grace that Christ gives
him. Man must be a co-worker with Christ
in the labor of overcoming and then he
will be partaker with Christ in his
glory. Close quote.
If God cannot save man against his will
from the power of Satan, that would mean
God can't save anyone.
Anyone.
This shows that Adomist theology does
not have a biblical anthropology.
Their view of man is not rooted in
scripture.
They focus so much on if conditional
immortality and that they they don't
even get the the basic anthropology of
man in terms of his sinful condition
down. The Bible makes it clear, folks,
particularly Romans chapter 2 and 3,
that man is naturally hostile to God, a
hater of God, cannot do any good, cannot
seek for God, is a slave to sin, by
nature, a child of wrath, a resident in
the kingdom of darkness, and so on.
So, a person makes choices consistent
with that nature, which are choices that
reflect being a slave to sin.
So, if God can't save anyone from that,
it's just such a weak depiction of of
the Almighty. It's crazy. But notice
again, man has to do his due diligence
with the help of divine aid, of course,
to overcome as perfectly as Christ did.
Well, you're already screwed, folks.
It's not, well, he can give you, he's
able to give you a clean slate and then
moving forward. Well, I I confess every
time that I'm aware. And no, no. The
standard is complete perfection.
Thought, word, deed, motive. You have to
be loving God perfectly with every
thought, word, and deed. Just rest in
Christ. Trust that God will continue to
shape you, to mold you. You are accepted
in Christ. Doesn't matter. On my best
day, on my best day, I'm still,
metaphorically speaking, I'm still
looking at rock bottom from the, you
know, rock bottom's above me on my best
day. You need to see how high the
standard is, folks.
She says, once you've once you've done
that, you've overcome perfectly as
Christ did, then you become an heir of
God and joint heir with Christ. Again,
false. She is using language from Romans
8:17 here, but leaving out what Paul
says at the beginning of the verse. If
we are children of God, presently, we
are presently hes with Christ. Yes,
there is a now and a not yet component.
I'm not physically seated with Christ
yet, but Ephesians does tell us we're
seated with Christ in the heavenlies
presently. So, yeah, there is a now and
a not yet component, but this is talking
so teologically.
You get yourself to that point with the
help of the Holy Spirit, then you can be
found to be a child of God.
But it's presently Paul tells us in
multiple places this encompasses the
biblical doctrine of adoption, being
transferred from the kingdom of darkness
to the kingdom of light, etc. So
believers by being in Christ have zero
condemnation and nothing can condemn
them. Romans 8:1. And they are already
children of God. Galatians 3. They are
obviously there are obviously far more
quotes that we could look at, but this
demonstrates why answering Adventism
holds the position that it does. In this
system, the good news or gospel is that
Jesus opened the door of salvation and
offers probation, probation extension
really to anyone who repents.
You then are given divine power to to
now start keeping the law perfectly. And
because you have faith in Jesus's
merits, your lawkeeping is seen as
acceptable. Once then through your
diligent efforts, you get to a place of
perfect lawkeeping, you will then be
accounted worthy and be reconciled to
God.
This is a worksbased mess that mixes the
law and the gospel which are not to be
mixed or you create a false gospel.
No works-based group says we teach a
worksbased salvation. Of course not. No
one does. There find me the group out
there that's like, "Yeah, we teach a
worksbased salvation."
So, I don't expect this group to be any
different. But it does not change the
facts. This is a false gospel. And Paul
made it clear as we saw in Galatians 1
6-12 or 6-9 really that there's only one
gospel. And adding to that gospel
produces a cursed gospel. And this isn't
even getting into all of the issues on
top of this false view of
reconciliation.
You have a host of other doctrinal
things that we have to adhere to.
Yes. Ellen White labeled these things
gospel.
First one on the list, for example,
investigative judgment. She said, "You
have to believe this in order to have
the the faith that you'll need to be
able to make it." These are salvational
issues. This is the present truth
message supposedly.
So, look at these investigative
judgment. What they'll say, Christ work
in the heavenly sanctuary.
You have to leave apostate churches and
join the Adventist church, which is the
remnant.
Seventh day Sabbath observance because
of the seal of God and the mark of the
beast teaching
the health message, the right arm of the
gospel. Got to get into that physically
fit state to work to to be fit for the
the new heaven and the new earth.
Ellen White's writings, the spirit of
prophecy
because that's how you get the the three
the fullness of the three angels
message. You can't find all this stuff
in Revelation 14.
State of the dead, conditional
immortality. could even add on this list
young earth creationism because if
you're not affirming young earth
creationism, well, you don't worship the
one true God.
The point is is that none of this is the
gospel.
None of it.
None of that is the gospel.
The good news about God himself entering
into creation to save a people, his
doing so successfully, redeeming all of
creation, that you can be reconciled to
God by faith in the perfect and
completed work of Jesus Christ. That his
kingdom has arrived. That he's ruling
and reigning with all authority right
now while all of his enemies are being
made a foottool. The gospel of the
kingdom that Jesus went around
preaching, Luke 8, for example,
that's the gospel. the good news that
you can have forgiveness and
reconciliation with God and have union
with your maker forever. He will
remember none of all He will remember
none of your sins. He will blot them out
as far as the east is from the west.
Part of the promise of the new covenant
is that God will not remember your sins
anymore. Jeremiah 31.
He will be a god to you and your
children.
He's going to come back one day to throw
the wicked out and lift the curse off
this present creation. There's all these
these promises and benefits. This stuff
is is the gospel message, the power of
God to salvation. Being a vegan,
believing something happened in 1844
that no one else saw, going to church on
Saturday, Ellen White's writings, and
believing hell isn't eternal and that
the wicked, you know, will not burn
forever. None of that is the gospel.
Hell is not the gospel. I hear that
frequently. Well, you you guys preach
that hell is forever. That has nothing
to do Hell is not the gospel. That's not
the good news.
The gospel is the power of God to
salvation, folks. It's theology, not not
the gospel message. All that stuff is is
theology. It's not the gospel message.
By all that stuff, I mean the stuff that
was on that previous slide.
Again, Paul calls the gospel the power
of God unto salvation. Romans 1:16-1 17.
It is the good news about salvation and
how a person can be made right with God.
But before looking at a couple of
statements regarding the Adventist
Jesus, there'll only be two because it
doesn't take very much on this one.
Adventists, this is what Ellen White's
exhortation to you is. And I want you to
take her up on this exhortation. Okay?
she says,
get this brought up here.
So, notice
the truth. I'm going to start right
here.
Whoops.
The truth must be presented in its
simplicity. She's talking about the
Adventist message here.
and laid out in clear lines. We are in
no case to hide our light under a bushel
as if ashamed of it. We have nothing of
which to be ashamed. The commandments of
God are to be honored above the
traditions and commandments of men. This
is from review and herald July 7 1891 by
the way.
Then brethren, use wisely the precious
light that God has given presenting it
to the people in the meekness and
gentleness of Christ. Meet the prejudice
of the people with an invitation such as
Philip gave Nathaniel. Come and see.
Say, if Seventh Day Adventists have the
truth, and can prove it so from the
oracles of God, you do not wish to be
found fighting against God.
We are to be bodies of light proclaiming
Christ and his love to the people and
presenting all of our doctrines in their
true relation to this important theme.
We must meet opposition and unbelief.
The truth has always had to meet these
elements. In the days of Christ, the
scribes and Pharisees were filled with
opposition to his work. When it was
declared that God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish, but have everlasting life, they
were as full of criticisms and prejudice
at this statement as are the people
today when they hear the doctrines held
by the Seventh Day Adventists.
We shall have to meet people as full of
hatred to our work as were the priests
and rulers in the days of Christ uh of
Christ to his work. It is our duty,
however, to diffuse light in every
direction and lay out in clear lines
what the sinner must do in order to
obtain eternal life.
So, Adventist,
I want you to adhere to this advice and
come and engage. I see that we have
somebody in Q here. So, real quick,
let's uh look at, like I said, these two
slides here as it pertains to the
Adventist Jesus. Now, there is a lot
that we could look at here. Like I said,
I have a playlist of this on the
channel. We're still actually finishing
up those videos. They're not done. And
it's going to be a few more parts, but
it doesn't require looking at a lot of
these to see why we hold the position
that we do here. Remember, Paul clearly
says 2 Corinthians 11 1-4, a different
Jesus. There are false Jesuses out
there. Simply using the name does not
cut it. Who are you talking about? Who
is Jesus? Describe him. See if we're
talking about the same person. Okay.
So, first quote here.
God is the father of Christ. Christ is
the son of God. Okay. To Christ has been
given an exalted position. He has been
made equal with the father. All the
councils of God are open to his son.
Close quote. Complete and total
blasphemy.
This alone proves the point. Jesus
Christ is God Almighty. If you're an
Adventist and you disagree, join. Let's
discuss it. Let's see what the
scriptures teach. Jesus Christ was not
made equal with the father. And this
statement is is is commenting about
excuse me prior to the incarnation. So
you can't even try well he was exalted
yet that's that's something completely
different that's talking about in his
humanity etc. This is not
to piggyback off of this. We've looked
at this before.
Quote Spirit of Prophecy Volume 1 page
17. The great creator assembled the
heavenly host that he might in the
presence of all the angels confer
special honor upon his son. The son was
seated on the throne with the father and
the heavenly throne of holy angels was
gathered around them. This is prior to
the creation of earth folks. The father
then made known that it was ordained by
himself that Christ his son should be
equal with himself. So that wherever was
the presence of the of his yeah of his
son, it was as his own presence. Close
quote. So prior to the creation of the
earth in this pre-earth origin story
that the great controversy narrative is
born out of, Jesus was exalted to be
made equal with the father.
She goes on to say that this made
Lucifer jealous which triggered his
rebellion and this is foundational in
Adventism because it informs why the
great controversy is happening, why
Jesus had to come to earth, why the
incarnation happened, what the atonement
was about, etc. Without this exaltation
aspect, you don't have the supposed
great controversy taking place. So yes,
it is a must. It is the first domino in
a chain of dominoes.
And remember, the Adventist Church
upholds this as divinely inspired from
the throne room of God. Now, there are
far more reasons, like I said, why the
Adventist Jesus is false. The claim that
he's only a man on earth like we are. He
couldn't see through the portals of the
tomb because Satan was able to twist his
heart. Apparently, he's a Levitical
priest up in heaven, still dealing with
sin, etc. But that suffices. This is a
false Jesus. So with that said, we have
our first guest here, the baseball
lover.
The baseball lover. Welcome. You are
live, Matt.
Hello. Hello.
Hello.
Yeah. So, uh what uh what would you like
to what aspect would you like to
discuss?
Yeah. Um you were so there was a lot
said can't answer everything but when
you were u on page 156 of sons and
daughters
you you kind of mischaracterized it
nowhere there said that you have to
follow the law perfectly in order to be
saved. Um I don't know where she said
that.
I'm looking at the slide now that you
had
Yeah. Do you do you want quotes on that?
Uh yeah, I just from the slide that you
had up, I didn't see that.
Right. Well, I didn't say it was in the
the slide there. I was basically
speaking upon the the system itself. Do
you think that Ellen White doesn't
didn't teach that
perfectly? Like without error, you'll
never sin again.
Um
well, no,
no, no, no. That not I'm not saying that
she was saying on on a dime you'll just
from that moment on it'll just be bam.
It's that you have to get to a sinlessly
perfect state,
right? that we're we're reaching for
perfection. I believe that we're
reaching for perfection.
Mhm.
Um
and unless you get there, you're not
going to make it. You want the quotes on
that?
Sure.
Okay.
So, most of these here are going to be
from Christ in the Sanctuary. Are you
familiar with that book?
I've heard it. I haven't read it.
It's a It's a compilation book. It's
pulled from published works, obviously,
and it's just all of her stuff on the uh
sanctuary teaching. Okay.
What's it called again? So Christ in his
sanctuary. So I'll I'll bring it up here
on screen for us though. So because the
reason I'm I'm saying that is because um
when I talk sometimes I I talk from a
standpoint obviously of
um a person who's thinking about the
whole system here. And so sometimes I I
comment and forget that not everybody
who's listening is is tuned in on on
some of those things. So just a second
here. Let me share the screen for us.
Okay. Christess Sanctuary. This is page
167. Okay.
Yeah. 167 says
Yep. Um let me find it on here because I
have it in my notes, but it's I'm going
to start right here where it says the
work of judgment. Okay.
This is the standard. This is the
standard to pass and you have to pass
the investigative judgment to be
reconciled to God. Okay. You agree?
Yeah.
Yep.
So far so
Okay. So she Yep. So she says
uh sorry I lost my spot. Um
sorry the work of judgment which began
in 1844 must continue until the cases of
all are decided both of the living and
of the dead. Hence, it will be extended
to the close of human probation that men
may be prepared to stand in the
judgment. The message commands them to
fear God and give glory to him and
worship him that made heaven and earth
and the sea and the fountains of waters.
The result of an acceptance of these
messages is given in the word. Here are
they that keep the commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus. In order to be
prepared for the judgment, it's
necessary that men should keep the law
of God. That law will be the standard of
character in the judgment. Close quote.
Same book a few pages later.
Three.
Quote, "The law of God is the standard
by which the characters and lives of men
will be tested in the judgment. Says the
wise man, fear God and keep his
commandments, for this is the whole duty
of man, for God shall bring every work
into judgment." Which is a quote from
Ecclesiastes, which isn't talking about
siriology. The apostle James admonished
his brethren. So speak ye and do so so
that ye shall be judged by the law of
liberty. Those who in the judgment are
accounted worthy will have a part in the
resurrection of the just.
So what do you believe her to be saying
there?
Yeah, there's no there's no the word
perfection does not appear there.
Right. But the reason it doesn't have to
be there is because if there's a sin on
your record, it will keep you from
entering.
Right. I I've um I I've spoken to many
leaders and if we do fall short, we can
confess our sins just like it says in
first John. So the standard isn't
perfection like you'll never sin again.
Um some Adventists do believe in sin is
perfection like John Wesley did. But the
majority that I that throughout the
church throughout the churches that I've
oh recognize don't teach perfection like
that. You can confess if you do sin.
Well I I don't necessarily care what
other leaders say. I mean, you're going
to get people that say all sorts of
stuff. I get Adventists all the time
that are commenting on here and say,
"Well, I believe this and the Adventist
church is wrong on this." I mean, you
can find people all across the board.
That's why we're I'm I'm trying to site
primary source materials here. But
again, it doesn't have to say the word
perfect for that to be the logical
conclusion. If there is any sin on your
record when your name comes up and it's
not confessed, here you go. How solemn
is the thought? Remember, this is only
for for professed believers, right? It's
not for the lost. Correct. It's only for
the the professing believer all the way
back to Adam. Right.
Right.
Okay. How solemn is the thought? Day
after day, passing into eternity bears
its burden of records for the books of
heaven. Words once spoken, deeds once
done, can never be recalled. Angels have
registered both the good and the evil.
The mightiest conqueror upon the earth
cannot call back the record of even a
single day. Our acts, our words, even
our most secret motives, all have their
weight in deciding our destiny for will
or woe. Though they may be forgotten by
us, they will bear their testimony to
justify or to condemn. So if you have
any sin on your record when Jesus is
going down the list of your sins, have
you confessed every single sin that
you've committed, sir?
Every sin that I've known, every any sin
possible that I recognize. every night
before I go to bed when I do commit
something um that I know is a sin um as
as much as my will is
my my genuine sincerity is in place.
Anything I've committed knowledgewise
I've confessed. I even confess her sins
that I don't know I've committed. soul.
Well, well, see, so right. The the point
is is that you're living in a constant
state of worry and concern because you
can't possibly know that you have
confessed every single sin because how
do you confess a sin that you've
forgotten,
right? Um you you just confess like
Jesus said in his Lord's prayer, um
forgive us our sins as we forgive others
who sin against us. Um, so yeah, I
wanted also to so that's a base that's
not just an Adventist issue. That's the
the Methodists also believe that as
well. Um, yes. You're you strive for
Christian perfection because Jesus said
be perfect for your heavenly father is
perfect.
Yeah. No. So you want to go to that
Matthew 5?
Yeah.
Okay. That's that's not talking about
sotiology, my man. Um, you have to
understand what's going on here. Jesus
is is preaching the sermon on the mount
here. You're talking about Matthew 5:48.
Um, so here's how you guys are are
thinking that this is being said.
So, we'll start at verse 43 here where
he's talking about love your enemies.
You've heard that it was said, but he's
he's been saying so when he says you've
heard what that it was said, what do you
think is being referenced there? What is
he referring to when he says you've
heard this was said?
It's probably oral tradition. Um,
so what we're about to read is from oral
tradition.
Yeah. What what what's the verse
exactly?
Matthew 54 43-48
5.
I'll give you I'll give you a help. Um
it's definitely not only oral tradition
because Jesus is expounding upon the law
in Matthew 5.
Yeah.
So there's some things in the sermon on
the mount that he was also answering
oral tradition that we don't find in the
Old Testament.
Some things.
So he says, "You've heard that it was
said, but what he says next is not oral
tradition. You shall love your neighbor
and hate your enemy. But I say to you,
love your enemies and pray for those who
persecute you, so that you may be sons
of your father who's in heaven. For he
makes his son rise on the evil and on
the good and sends rain on the just and
on the unjust. For if you love those who
love you, what reward do you have? Do
not even the tax collectors do the same?
And if you greet only your brothers,
what more are you doing than others? Do
not even the Gentiles do the same? You
therefore must be perfect as your
heavenly father is perfect. What do you
think he is teaching here? What describe
this. What is Jesus's point in saying
all this?
It's very similar to what he said when
he said if you don't forgive your
brother when
if you don't forgive your brother you
God will not forgive you. So belief also
encompasses life. If if you have faith
you will also have life in the Holy
Spirit. And so Christians will obey the
law. Christians when when they believe
in Jesus, they will receive the power of
the Holy Spirit and be perfected in
their walk with God and they will be
sanctified to obey the law. Um and to be
perfect, striving for perfection as long
as your heavenly father is perfect. Um
and and David sinned in the Old
Testament. So by this stand so by that
standard um nobody the David isn't even
saved at all, but he did confess and
then he continued to live a life of
perfection. That's a standard inter
interpretation of Christian perfection.
Obey the law. Also, he said, "If your
law if your righteousness does not
exceed that of the of the Pharisees, you
will by no means enter."
Okay. So, back to Matthew 5, though,
because there's there's a lot there. And
when we jump around like that, we're
we're we miss stuff in in the path.
Sure.
Um Jesus is not teaching sotologically
in Matthew 5. That's the core issue. The
way that you guys would read that is to
say, "Be ye perfect as your father in
heaven is perfect and then asterisk" if
you want to be saved. That's not what
what Jesus is saying. Jesus is actually,
if you look at the whole sermon on the
mount, this is why the reformed churches
um Lutheran, Presbyterians, etc. preach
utilizing and believe it or not yes
Wesley which Wesley left from
Anglicanism into Methodism and um
there's a whole sort of chain there but
that's why they embrace what is called
the law gospel distinction because every
sermon every Lord's day is from there is
law preached and there is gospel
preached because both are necessary
because each have a specific function
but you cannot intermix the two of them
so you're reading Jesus's words there be
perfect as your father in heaven is
perfect where he is laying out the
standard and you're thinking that what's
being said is oh man I've got to get my
character together and try and you know
hit this mark in this standard so that I
can be saved. That's not what Jesus is
saying. Jesus is pointing out how far
you fall short. Any person that would
have been hearing this message who's
honest would have internally been saying
wow I don't measure up. Jesus
transitions to the gospel later on in
Matthew in the same sermon. So he starts
with the law which is supposed to bring
condemnation and an increase of sin etc.
which is or an increased knowledge of
sin like Paul talks about um but the law
does not justify the law is not a
reconciliation tool. So what the
adventist church has done and I don't
care if you appeal to other groups you
know I don't you know Methodist or
whatever um if you meld together the law
and the gospel you don't have the
gospel. You you've changed the gospel.
So what you're doing when you read
Matthew 5 that way is you're
intermingling the law with the gospel
which really gets us to the the crux of
why I was wanting to read those quotes
earlier which was predominantly around
reconciliation not necessarily um the
the standard of did did it say that you
have to you know
sure
per you know are are you are you
absolutely perfect but rather what do
you believe about being reconciled? What
do you think reconciles a person to God?
Do you agree with the the quote from
testimonies for the church volume 4?
Um which quote specifically?
Man who has defaced the image of God in
his soul by corrupt life cannot by mere
human effort affect a radical change in
himself. He must accept the provisions
of the gospel. He must be reconciled to
God through obedience to his law and
faith in Jesus Christ. Do you agree with
that?
Yeah. They're synonymous. They're one
and the same. If you have faith in
Jesus, you will love his law. Um unless
you're an antonyomianism. Unless you
believe in antonyomian. I'm not an
Antonyomian and I don't agree with that.
You're this is why um this is why my my
friend we have to be very specific about
these things.
Sure.
The law does not reconcile you
that just because you you believe that
doesn't mean that you therefore are an
antonyomian.
Are you aware of that?
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
Because you can say the law has a
purpose but it's not to be reconciled.
Okay. Um
an Antonyomian would say unhitch it all.
Those are Marianites and that's a fringe
minority and and Christians historically
have have not embraced that. That's a
heresy that's been denounced since the
4th century.
Yeah, it's been a great line throughout
church history. I agree with that. Um
may may sorry you want to finish your
point or um
Well, I was just going to say I if if
that is the the teaching then why is
that not what we see when we look at the
apostolic teaching? Because the
apostolic teaching is not that you are
reconciled by faith and obedience to the
law. That the law and faith reconcile.
Okay. I have two more passages I would
like to go over with you if you don't
mind.
Is it about is it about reconciliation?
Um
one is about it uses the words eternal
life. One's from Jesus, the other is
from Paul.
Y
So I would like to address those two if
you have time.
No, we we do. We we'll get to that.
Let's stick on on this real quick
because again the reason I was primarily
quoting those was to predominantly talk
about the reconciliation aspect.
Yeah.
Um and
we looked at that where Ellen says
you're reconciled to God by faith and
obedience to the law.
Okay. It's a joint a joint thing. Here's
what Paul says. This is after Romans 4.
He's used Abraham as an example quoting
Genesis 15:6 154-6 talking about how a
person is justified before God just like
Abraham.
He then says, "Therefore," that's what
the therefore is there for. Since we
have been justified by faith, we have
peace with God through our Lord Jesus
Christ.
Reconciliation is a part of having peace
with God.
That's done by faith. Through him, we've
also obtained. So again, through him, in
him, in Christ, these are terms of union
with Christ. Through him, we've also
obtained access by faith into this grace
in which we which we stand. And we
rejoice in hope of the glory of God. Not
only that, but we rejoice in our
sufferings, knowing that suffering
produces endurance, and endurance
produces character, and character
produces hope, and hope does uh hope
does not put to shame because God's love
has been poured into our hearts through
the Holy Spirit who's been given to us.
For while we were still weak, at the
right time, Christ died for the ungodly.
For one will scarcely die for a
righteous person, though perhaps for a
good person, one would dare even to die.
But God shows his love for us in that
while we were still sinners, that means
not obeying. Correct?
Yeah.
Christ died for us.
Amen.
Since there since therefore we've now
been justified by his blood, much more
shall we be saved by him from the wrath
of God. For if while we were enemies, so
he's doing a parenthetical here. Do you
know what that is?
He's now repeating the same thing that
he just said, but now saying it
essentially a little bit of a different
way.
Sure.
So he says, "Since therefore we have now
been justified by his blood, much more
shall we be saved by him from the wrath
of God. For if while we were enemies,
earlier it was while we were still
sinners, we were reconciled to God by
the death of his son, much more now that
we are reconciled, shall we be saved by
his life. More than that, we also
rejoice in God through our Lord Jesus
Christ through whom we now received
reconciliation.
Amen. Amen to all of that. I
wholeheartedly
nothing there about obedience to the law
reconciling you. Nothing. Paul's already
talked about the law back in chapters
three and chapter 4. He's going to talk
about it again a little bit later, but
he never talks about the law being a
reconciliation device.
Right. Okay. Okay. So then, so then
let's stick with Paul.
Um I was going to quote Jesus, but we
can stick with Paul.
Uh G Paul talks about two laws. The law
of Christ and the law of sin and death.
And so we are now under the law of
Christ through faith. And so once you're
under the law of Christ, you have to
obey that law. It's part of the new the
new covenant.
I think reconciliation is part of the
old covenant.
Um and I'll use Paul's words in Romans
8. Uh okay. Paul said
start at 8 start at 81.
Sure. Um
yeah Romans 8
verse okay. It says for if you live
according to the flesh you will die.
What verse
is I have it quoted here without the
let me just uh it if you if you if by by
the spirit put to death the deeds of the
flesh
ah 13
verse 13
for if you live according to the flesh
you will die but if by the spirit you
put to death the de misdeed needs of the
body, you will live. And so the same
Paul who's and I wholeheartedly agree it
it Jesus sanctifies by his sacrifice on
the cross. He's that's how he saved us.
Um that's how he initiates
justification. But and but Paul himself
says in Romans 8:13, you have to put to
death the deeds of the body so that you
will live by the spirit. So we're
obeying the law through the spirit. So
and we're following the law of Christ,
not the law of sin and death.
He he doesn't say anything there about
how you're reconciled. We're off the
topic now. Ellen White said, "You are
reconciled to God by faith and obedience
to the law." No, you're not. Paul did
not say that. Furthermore, you need to
start back at one because he just got
out of chapter 7, which I think is also
a very interesting um chapter because of
the nature it presses on uh the
Adventist understanding of the nature of
man. But he just got done talking about
how the new man wars with the old man.
how after you are changed and you are
regenerated essentially, you now have a
conviction and a conscious awareness to
sin that you didn't have before. And he
goes on to talk about the war that the
Christian experiences over the course of
their life. Um, I'm not disagreeing with
you that Christians have a changed life,
that Christians strive to to live holy
lives. That's not the argument at all.
The argument is where does anything in
here say that you are reconciled to God
by faith plus anything else because what
he says here at the beginning is this
this is after he has just talked about
well actually let's move back to uh the
tail end of of seven because we need to
trail into what he's getting at
sure because he says so I find it to be
that the that so I find it to be a law
that when I want to do right evil lies
close at hand For I delight in the law
of God. This is after in Romans 1 2 and
3, he's talked about how all people are
naturally haters of God um cannot do
what is pleasing to God. Those that are
in the flesh, etc. He's talking about
the lost. And he's explaining to Jews,
they're no better than Gentiles who
didn't have the law given to them. All
people are in the same boat. They're all
condemned.
Yeah.
So now he's talking about this this
conversion experience and the life of
the born again believer now. And he
says, "So I find it to be a law that
when I want to do right, evil lies close
at hand. For I delight in the law of God
in my inner being. Yeah, that's correct.
Believers want to live a life obedient
to God. But I see in my members another
law waging war against the law of my
mind and making me captive to the law of
sin that dwells in my members.
Wretched man that I am, who will deliver
me from this body of death? Thanks be to
God through Jesus Christ our Lord. So
then I myself serve the law of God with
my mind, but with my flesh I serve the
law of sin. Again, he's just continuing
that parallelism of the war that takes
place between the born again believer.
After saying that, he then says, "There
is therefore now no condemnation for
those who are in Christ Jesus." You guys
believe that there will be lots of
condemnation for those people
in Jesus.
Well, let me ask you, who is uh are you
in Christ now?
Absolutely.
How do you know that?
the work of the Holy has your name.
Well, what about if your name's already
come up and you didn't pass?
That doesn't happen till the final to
the end.
You don't know that.
Nobody Nobody really does until the end,
right? So, you can't possibly know that
you're in Christ then because for all
you know, there could be condemnation
for you.
Sure. By that standard, anybody, right?
Because we can follow.
Well, no. I No, I know that. No. No. I I
No. See, and that's the difference is
Jesus Christ is a savior. That means he
saves people. He's not just a helper
who's trying his best and he has desires
that he can't seem to bring about. Jesus
came for a people. So Jesus is a perfect
savior. Um once I'm born again, there's
not being unborn again. God is a is is
the author and finisher of my faith. So
no, when it says here, there's no no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus. No, I nothing can condemn me. No,
nothing.
Amen. As long as you're in Christ Jesus.
I I agree. As long as you're in Christ,
you have to be in Christ.
But you but the thing is you can't know
that you're in Christ. And you already
you just admitted that earlier because
in order to know that you're in Christ
in your system, you'd have to know that
you passed the investigative judgment.
Well, that's the f I I said that for the
future. You can't know for sure if you
will remain in Christ in the future. I
think I believe you can know now that
you're in Christ because of the way
you're living.
Your faith will demonstrate fruit. Uh,
but in the future, sure, I could fall
away. I I could become an atheist and so
can you.
If you become an atheist, you
Okay.
See, that's that's the difference, my
man. And that's the concern I have for
Adventists is um the the good news is
that Jesus is able and capable to to
save and your focus should be on him.
Notice the the stuff you said there. I
agree with, you know, some of the
general things that you you stated
throughout, but notice what you said.
you your focus is on you. Your focus is
on your behavior, on what you're doing.
That's what's either keeping you or not
keeping you. It's an anthropocentric
system. You're you're trusting in your
continued obedience that you'll continue
trying your hardest. That's not the
gospel, my man. That's not the gospel.
And I'm not poo pooing good works. Uh if
you knew my my
personal I mean, just I'm not an
Antonyomian. So understand I'm not
advocating for that. But
the reformed position the
well not even just not even just the
reformed position. It's not even unique
to I mean there's people that watch this
channel that are Roman Catholics,
Orthodox, Armenians, Provisionists, etc.
And they all uh you know talk about this
this same sort of thing. Uh I guess I
shouldn't say all, but I'm just saying I
know a number of people across the
spectrum. This isn't unique to to
Adventists. The point is is that that's
not being um that's not what being in
Christ is, my man. It's not being on a
probationary period to then see if
you'll remain as if God doesn't know his
people because then you're going to have
to deal with all the issues of the fact
that Jesus came for a people that he
knows like in John chapter 6. Um, and
that you're essentially saying that the
will of the father will not happen
because Jesus said that the will of the
father is that Jesus will lose none that
have been given to him but he'll raise
all of them up on the last day. So if he
loses some of those that would mean that
the will of the father is then and then
this this now gets into the whole chain
of of the plan of salvation and
redemption etc. But
um that
that's that's not the gospel man. You
don't have to be reformed to understand
that you shouldn't be looking to
yourself and your own doings and your
own behavior um to see if you're really
remaining in Christ. I'm not saying that
the the warning passages are not true,
but this is also why I think the
Adventist Church is weak eucharistic
theology is very dangerous as well
because that's why we're given a visible
sign. And I know that you don't agree
with this, but the the church
historically and and for the most part
has not held to these ving idea of a
mere memorial, but that we actually
partake of Christ and his benefits in
the the the Eucharist. And so, um, that
if you're looking to something external,
it should be the visible sign that God
has given to us that we partake of
weekly, which is Christ himself, which
is keeping our eyes on Christ by keeping
our eyes on that visible. That's why God
gave us a visible sign um through in
baptism and the supper. But um my man,
right? Because you're remaining in C.
You're abi by you doing all of that. You
are abiding in Christ.
And I agree with that. You have to abide
in Christ. Um and this is not a trick
question. I'm going to ask you a
question. It's not a trick question.
Was Ravi Zachariah is Ravi Zacharias in
hell today?
I don't know. We're not called to be
elect detectors.
Ah okay.
I I don't I don't know. I right I I know
we're called in scripture to go around I
Christians are called to take the
message and trust that God's going to do
what God is going to do. So there could
be all sorts of people who I think are
saved and aren't saved or you know
that's that's really futile um because
only God knows his heart essentially.
Right. Right.
Right. And and so I don't think Robbie
Zacharias abided in Christ towards the
last later years of his life.
Maybe if he had
Right. If if he had a mental disease
that made him do all those, okay, that
that's different. But as is if he
willfully did those things, he I in my
theology, he is not abiding in Christ.
And so I don't see how he saved at all.
And so I don't think he truly believed
or he did believe once and then he
stopped abiding in Christ. That's the
way I would approach that because Jesus
said in John 15,
if you do not bear fruit, I will cut you
off.
Yeah. Yeah. And there's there's
covenantal language going on there which
is re really important. But to to hit on
kind of something you said there. So do
you believe somebody can be born again,
unborn again, and then born again again?
Yeah, I see what you're saying. Born
again again. Oh, that's a
Well, that's what you're saying because
if if you think somebody can truly
believe that a goat can become a sheep
and then become a goat again. Um
I know I know I know I know what you're
saying. Um that to be honest I'm I'm not
sure that's debated because there's a
passages in Hebrews that says um if you
sin willfully after receiving the
knowledge of the truth there no longer
remains a sacrifice.
So this is this let's go look at it.
This is talking about covenant here. You
got to understand what's in view. He
says the same thing in chapter 10. You
have to understand covenant and what's
going on here because he's not saying if
you commit a sin after having a
knowledge of that thing being a sin.
Have you lied since knowing that lying
is wrong?
No I meant apostasy brother. I'm in
apostasy.
Yeah. Um and notice what he Go ahead.
Sorry.
Yeah. Just cuz you asked me, can you be
can you be born again, then lose it, and
then be born again again? And so then I
was referring to Hebrews, the warning
passage in Hebrews that can you lose
your salvation and then be born again
after that again. That Yeah, that's what
I meant by if you sin willfully.
Yeah. So this is in the whole book of
Hebrews is in the context of covenant.
Do you know who he's writing to?
Um, yeah, Jews considering falling away,
I believe,
consider, well, not just falling away,
they're specifically considering going
back to the old the the shadows, the
types, etc.,
right?
And and falling away from Christ. So,
when he says, uh, let's start at what
verse were you specifically referencing?
10:26.
Yeah. Well, 10, are you in six or 10?
I'm in chapter 10, verse 26.
Okay. Well, yep. So he says the same
thing here as well.
So this is after he has talked about um
the com cross comparison between Jesus
and MelkiseDC and then talking about the
drastic difference between the Levitical
and ironic priesthood. And then he he
says this here first. So this is the the
therefore what is the therefore
therefore? Well, he quotes something
from the Old Testament. He makes a
comparison here between the work that
Christ is doing with the work that the
Levitical priest was doing. And in verse
11 he says, "And every priest stands
daily at his service offering repeatedly
the same sacrifices which can never take
away sins." That was the Levitical
priest. But when Christ had offered for
all time a single sacrifice for sins. So
there's the first contrast. Multiple
sacrifices versus a single. He sat down.
There's the sec the next parallel. The
other priest stands. He sat down. The
other priest never sat down at the right
hand of God waiting from that time until
his enemies should be made a foottool
for his feet. Which is exactly what's
happening now. He's ruling and reigning
with all authority and making all of his
enemies a foottool. For by a single
offering he has perfected for all time.
There it is. There's that perfection
language that I was talking about
earlier that Christ is a perfect savior.
That the sacrifice of Christ all of
those that it was made for it perfects
those people.
Amen. Those were being sanctified. So
being sanctified in the present tense.
So they are living a life of
sanctification. I just want to add that
footnote.
Yeah. No, I I agree. I agree.
sanctification is is
obeying the law, but obeying the obeying
the law. I mean, what I don't know what
Well, it's more than it's more than just
that, my friend. That's the other thing.
Christ. Yeah. But
well, well, it's it's deeper than
you know.
Well, yeah. And there's a number of
things we could get off there, but let's
see what he says here. He says, "And the
Holy Spirit also bears witness to us for
after saying." So, do you know where
he's quoting from here?
Um, I believe it's Yeah. Jeremiah 51.
Jeremiah New
Covenant. Yep. Yep. Yep. So this is the
covenant I'll make with them after those
days, declares the Lord. I'll put my
laws on their hearts and write them on
their minds. Then he adds, I'll remember
their sins and their lawless deeds no
more. Do you believe that in the new
covenant?
Of course,
your sins are are so your sins are
already not remembered anymore. How can
Jesus be investigating sins that uh
don't exist?
Sins that don't exist.
Well, if he doesn't remember them
anymore, then how can he be
investigating sins he doesn't remember
anymore?
meaning he doesn't hold them against
you,
right?
Yeah. You confess your sins
to to to to be reconc uh to to be be
back in relationship with God because
you've offended God. He's your father.
Um that Jesus that's why Jesus says to
confess your sins in the Lord's prayer
on a daily basis. You can't disappoint
God even after you've been washed clean
by the blood of Christ. You can't sin
after believing. Um,
right. I don't doubt that. But this is
the difference between when you guys
quote first John uh 1:9, you know, he's
faithful and just to forgive us our
sins. That's being pulled out of a
larger uh homaly really that is talking
about a deeper issue than this
investigative judgment concept where
every time that you sin now you have to
confess it. If you don't confess it, you
know, you you thought a sinful thought
because you saw a billboard or then you
get creamed by a semi-truck. Oh, well,
you're lost now because you didn't
confess that. That's the sort of of
thing that you you start to set up. And
then it becomes this real granular thing
of, you know, have I confessed every
sin? You were saying earlier, oh, I I
confess every sin. I when I was an
Adventist, I was that same way. I I've
confessed every sin and God, every sin
I've forgotten, please forgive me of
that one, too. Notice again, we're back
to focusing on yourself. Yet, what's in
focus here is is Christ and the fact
that Christ is a perfect savior and part
of the promise of the new covenant,
which you enter into by by faith. Well,
really it's the visible sign of of
baptism and then um you're united to
Christ by faith in the in what we'd call
the invisible church. Those who are
truly born again, we can't see the
heart, so we don't know. We only see the
visible church around us. Part of the
promise of being in the the covenant is
that God will remember your sins and
lawless deeds no more. Well, in your
guys' system, that can't possibly be the
case because not only does he remember
them, he has an angel that he's assigned
over every individual to document down
all of your sins to report them back to
heaven for him to then investigate those
sins. But he continues and says, "Where
there is forgiveness of these, there's
no longer any offering for sin." It's
why we can have a cleansed conscience,
he goes on to talk about. But then he
says, "Therefore," so because of that,
brothers, since we have confidence to
enter the holy places by the blood of
Jesus, by the new and living way that he
opened for us through the curtain, that
is through his flesh, and since we have
a great priest over the house of God,
let us draw near with a true heart in
full assurance of faith, with our hearts
sprinkled clean from an evil conscience,
and our bodies washed with pure water.
So my man, if you have faith in Christ,
you shouldn't be frantically worrying
every day if there's any sins you've
forgotten to confess, etc. You should be
praying the Lord's prayer daily because
he commanded that. And I agree, we
should practice that um even multiple
times a day in my opinion. That's the
posture the Christian should take. But
if you think that because oh, I haven't
confessed this that there's a sin I've
forgotten about. This then gets into as
well the the truncated view of sin. My
man, the call is to love God perfectly
with every thought, word, deed, and
motive. It's not just the letter of the
Ten Commandments. Jesus explains that
actually further back in Matthew 5 where
we were at. He says, "You've heard that
you shouldn't commit adultery. Well, I
tell you, you even look at a woman with
lust." Well, that's not found in the
letter of the the law. So, it goes a lot
deeper than just the external letter.
And if you think that you've confessed
every sin, are you putting are you
putting Christ uh uh first in literally
everything that you do, thought, word,
and deed, every second, 24/7? No, not
the best that you can. No, not the best
you can. Are you
Are you No. Are you successful in that?
100% perfect.
100% perfect. The way you're the way
you're using that word perfect. No, I'm
going I'm trying to go by what Jesus
said in Matthew 6. Be perfect for your
heavenly father is perfect. And that way
that's Matthew effort with the Holy
Spirit's power.
Well, see that that's not what Jesus was
saying though in Matthew 5.
Right. Right. We
So what what Jesus was saying in Matthew
5 is is a is perfect. The way I'm I'm
defining it, do you know the Greek word
there and the tense of it?
It is not this idea of you've committed
sins before and now you've confessed
them and now because you've confessed
them you have a clean slate so you're
perfect. No, that's not the standard.
Jesus is the standard. Jesus never
sinned in thought, word, and deed. And
believers are given his active and
passive obedience. Jesus was obeying
perfectly not just externally the the
requirements of the law. Even in his
thought life, his desires, all of that
was perfect. His passive obedience which
was his
thought life second by second by second
as well as his active obedience, his
willful humiliation, his going to the
cross, his Matthew 3 being baptized that
it would be to fulfill all
righteousness, his actions, etc. That's
the standard. It's not you're trying
your best. Your your best is not even
good on your best day. It's not enough.
The standard is that level of perfection
by ourselves. I agree. We're not doing
it by ourselves. As Ellen White said,
I didn't say by yourself. I didn't say
power with the power of the Holy Spirit
grace of Jesus.
Right. So, what you're saying is you
have to get to a point through the help
of the Holy Spirit. Of course, this is
just standard synergism just kind of on
steroids.
With the help of the Holy Spirit, the
door has been opened. Your period of
probation has been extended. You are now
seeking with the help of the Holy Spirit
again by your faith to get to a place
where you are keeping the law perfectly.
What is the purpose of getting to that
point?
to fulfill what Jesus said
in the parable of the good Samaritan.
That's not about sotiology, my man. That
parable is not about sotiology. That's
mind if I read mind if I read um mind if
I quote the verses?
Let's hold off. We'll get to that. Hold
off on that. Let's finish what what was
here because I'm sorry. I know I kind of
sidetracked us there. Um but I want to
get to the verse that you were talking
about because we were initially talking
about what was being said here in in
10:26 in Hebrews. Hebrews 10:26 cuz it's
talking here about covenant and he just
got done saying all this stuff he's gone
through a number of things in 1 through
uh 9 all sorts of parallels and and
differences.
Sure. Jeremiah and the in the new
covenant.
Yep. Yep. Yep. And the promise because
he's again he's trying to implore them
and remind them because these are people
who are tempted to go back to the types
and the shadows. So he says, "Let us
draw near with a true heart in full
assurance of faith, with our hearts
sprinkled clean from an evil conscience
and our bodies washed with pure water.
Let us hold fast the confession of our
hope without wavering. For he who
promised is faithful. And let us
consider how to stir up one another to
love and good works, not neglecting to
meet together, as is the habit of some,
but encouraging one another, and all the
more as you see the day drawing near.
For if we go on sinning deliberately
after receiving the knowledge of the
truth, there no longer remains, notice
what's here, a sacrifice for sins. Why
does he tack on that tail end part?
There no longer remains a sacrifice for
sins
because
if we go on sinning deliberately after
receiving a knowledge of the truth,
there no longer remains a sacrifice for
sins,
but a fearful expectation of judgment
and a fury of fire that will consume the
adversaries. Why does he tack on there
no longer remains a sacrifice for sins?
Because once you've denied, once you've
aposticized,
trampled on the the sacrifice of Jesus,
what else do you have after that? What
else does Ravi Zachcharias have if he
denies Christ? What what else? It's only
one sacrifice for all time, forever,
which is Jesus.
Yeah. So he says, if we go on sinning
deliberately after receiving the
knowledge of the truth, there no longer
remains a sacrifice for sins. What is
the will? What is the sinning
deliberately that he's that's in
reference there?
A typical
you got the second
I'm just going to use this example is
the simplest one what Ravi Zacharias did
the denying the Holy Spirit denying the
the grace of Christ just falling away
from faith saying no no no more or
becoming an atheist you you you you're
falling away from God you've denied the
grace that God has given you. So you
think the author is saying if a person
goes on committing sins, they're going
to fall away from Christ
because there no longer remains a
sacrifice for sins.
Um I that's that's not the way I put it.
Sorry, I was just trying to like repeat
it because I was thinking of the Robbie
Zachcharias example.
I'm just because it's just the only
example in my head that we can relate
with because we're we're from two
different camps. Um,
well, I would argue that what I'm
presenting here isn't necessarily unique
to my my camp, per se. Um, because
what's going on here, the reason he's
saying this is because, again, these are
people who are tempted to go back to the
shadow, the type, if you will. And he's
explaining to them after he just got
done talking specifically for three
chapters about the priestly work of
Christ in MelkiseDC in comparison to the
Levitical ironic priest.
He just got done talking about
sacrifices. That's why he's bringing
this up. He mentions it in Hebrews 9:24.
He mentions it in a number of places
leading up to this. The whole point of
what he's getting at here is that if you
go back to those things that you're
tempted to go back to as a Jew, which
they would have been tempted, think
about this, living in a period of time
where you're on the cusp of a
transition. This is more than likely
written before the destruction of the
temple in 70 AD because there's no
mention of that going on here. And it's
clear that these people were tempted to
go back to those things. Well, how could
they be tempted to go back to those
things if the temple's not there
anymore?
Okay, so this book doesn't really apply
to most Christian Oh, sorry. Sorry.
No, no, I'm not saying that. I'm not
saying that. So, in the in the Bible,
there's any given passage only has one
correct interpretation, but it can have
multiple applications. In order to
understand the proper applications, we
have to know the correct interpretation.
And in order to find that, we have to
see what the author's intended meaning
was in writing this. So he was writing
this to an initial audience. We have to
understand why was it written to them to
then find out how it applies to us
today. We don't want to read it denuted
from that in history and then try and
read a bunch of stuff into it without
understanding the historical context.
This is actually utilizing what's called
the historical grammatical method of
interpretation by the way which is what
Ted Wilson says is the only approved uh
hermeneutic in the SDA church. So he's
just got done talking about the law work
specifically. These were people who
lived on the cusp of a of the Judeaic
eon shifting to the new covenant eon, if
you will. And it would have been very
tempting, maybe not obviously in our day
and age, but it would have been very
tempting for them to go back to what
they were comfortable with. The idea of
there's only one single sacrifice and
it's over. He just got done talking
about us that in contrast to the
Levitical ironic priest where there were
sacrifices daily, this was a single
sacrifice. Keep your eyes on Christ.
Don't try and go back to other
sacrifices. If you do that, there is no
more sacrifices for sin. There the
sacrifice has already taken place. So
don't go back to that. That's what he's
referring to when he's talking about
going on sinning deliberately. He's
talking about going back to these old
sorts of things.
He's not saying because contextually
there's no reason to think that what
he's talking about here is if we uh I'm
not saying that uh you should just go on
sinning. I'm not advocating for that
obviously. Um, but contextually
speaking, what is in reference here is
people who are tempted to, which would
be sinful, to go back to the types and
shadows as if the substance hasn't come,
which I would argue is actually true for
the seventh day Sabbath, by the way, as
well. Um, but it's going back to the
type and the shadow, which is actually
what's in view here. And he's explaining
to them, well, there are no more
sacrifices. If you go back to
sacrificing goats and lambs, etc., Well,
there remains no more sacrifice for your
sins because those things have already
been fulfilled in the substance which is
Christ. Which is why there'll be a
fearful expectation of judgment and fury
of fire that will consume the
adversaries. Anyone who has set aside
the law of Moses dies without mercy on
the evidence of two or three witnesses.
How much worse punishment? So, he's he's
using that as an example. Anyone who set
aside the law of Moses dies without
mercy on the evidence of two or three
witnesses, which the law called for. You
had to have two or three witnesses um in
order for a charge to be lawfully
brought. How much worse punishment do
you think will be deserved by the one
who's trampled underfoot the son of God
and has profained the blood of the
covenant by which he was sanctified and
has outraged the spirit of grace. That's
where we get the insight into what these
people were tempted to do. Going back to
the sacrifices of goats, lambs, etc. is
trampling underfoot the son of god. So
the broader thing is getting into co uh
covenant here. These people who do this
are covenant breakers. There are people
who are in the covenant, the wheat and
the tears who are not regenerate. This
is getting us back to the primary reason
why we came here because you mentioned
this to say um why I was bringing up how
go Christ is a perfect savior who came
for a people and he saves those people
perfectly and you're reconciled through
your faith and God will essentially keep
those people. And so we jumped here to
where you said that it it could be
talking about um well there are people
who seem to be you know born again who
then can become unborn again. No, these
people who do this are covenant
breakers. They're in the visible
covenant community of God's people. They
go to your church. They're there every
week. You know, they had a baptism.
They're on fire for five years. They're
leading a class. They're in a Bible
study, etc. The flame goes out and they
just they leave. You think that person
was actually born again?
No. They weren't. That person was a is a
covenant breaker. They may have visibly
been in the covenant community of God's
people, entered in by way of baptism.
They're there worshiping, their hands
are up or, you know, whatever your
liturgy style is. Um, they're part of a
small group, etc. But then they just
they fall off. That person is a covenant
breaker. That person was not united to
Christ by by faith. That person had a
false faith or had, you know,
self-deception is a real thing, etc. So,
it's not that a person um actually lost
or or became unborn again and then at a
later point could potentially become
born again again, but rather it's it's
talking about a person who profained the
provisions of the covenant by being a
covenant breaker. And evidences that
they went out from us because they never
were truly of us.
Okay? They were never truly of us. There
are two phrases there that I think I see
indicate that they weren't they were I
agree with you. they were covenant
breakers, but that they were originally
in the new covenant and they lost that
grace. There are two indications there
that I see in this very same passage
in verse 29.
It says, "He who was trampled underfoot,
the son of God, profane the blood of the
covenant, quote, which was sanctified."
And so, so, so if you're saying that
they were never truly saved, you're
saying God sanctifies unbelievers. Um
and the second one and then I and then
I'll give your response is okay
the Lord will judge his people verse 30.
So he is telling Christians the Lord
will judge his people after giving a
threat of willfully sinning. And so for
me that indicates they were truly in the
covenant.
All right. I was trying to take notes
here because I don't want to forget that
that first thing that you said. Um, yes,
my man. People that are in covenant
community do experience the blessings of
that. Think about in national Israel. If
if you were in,
excuse me, if you were in national
Israel, but you were not actually
attached to God, you still experienced
the benefits of being in the covenant
community. Even if you were not truly
saved, there were people amongst Israel
who was not truly saved. You weren't you
weren't saved just because you were a
national Israelite,
right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Right. So there were people in covenant
community with God's people who
experienced the benefits of that but are
not actually attached to Christ by
faith. So yes, the people here who
trample underfoot the son of God, they
profane the blood of the covenant by
which he was sanctified.
Yes, absolutely. That can happen without
a person actually being united to Christ
by faith. Because the real core because
the real core comes down to what does
being united to Christ by faith mean
which is what I was talking about
earlier in the the stream and why I was
and why on this channel we emphasize it
so much these phrases in Christ you're
adopted you're transferred from the
kingdom of darkness into the kingdom of
light you are regenerated you are born
again you are again adopted you are
engrafted all of this language is union
with Christ language so you have to take
all of that into consideration here and
say was a person adopted, engrafted,
that God remembers their sins no more.
All of this stuff, this long list of
stuff. But then if they by their own
efforts end up falling away, that can
thwart all these things that God did and
then they can come back again and then
God will redo all of that stuff again.
He'll have another adoption service,
etc. That's essentially the logical
conclusion of what you'd have to say
there. Which is why I was asking that
original question of just do you think
somebody can be born again?
Okay.
Because it have to be you could be born
again and then be unborn again but then
be be born again. Shoot that could
happen who knows how many times at what
point can do you draw the line in that?
Yeah. I would
Isn't it just more consistent to think
that God who says he's the author and
finisher of our faith is the author and
finisher of our faith and that God is
able to save people.
God is able to save people and he is the
author and finisher of our faith. But I
think it's too simplistic to say
therefore that doesn't that means that
if you're once once you are in God's
grace,
you will never be able to fall away or
apostasize. I know millions of I we see
millions of Christians who live holy
lives and profess Jesus just like
Zacharias who then fall away. Um and and
and it's there's there's for me there's
numerous verses by Paul by Paul's mouth
himself, not just in Hebrews.
I just um I gotta go soon. Um thank you
for the conversation. I want to give one
more verse from Paul. Um and maybe
another day we can talk about what Jesus
said. Um
one more verse and this is why I believe
you can't fall from the grace because it
is a new covenant and a better covenant,
but you have to remain in Christ. You
have to be in Christ. So, um, Romans
11:22.
Okay. I'll I'll go there and bring it up
on screen for us. Just a second. I'll
also preface by saying, um, I didn't
really want to get into this tonight
because I don't necessarily think that
this is uh
uh I don't think this is necessarily uh
why the Adventist Church has a false
gospel. I have lots of friends that
don't agree with me on perseverance. Um,
and that's not what I think the the real
issue is. So, I wish we could have honed
in a little bit more on that, but it's
been a good discussion. You've been a
nice guy and so yeah, I have I've
appreciated that.
Um, so let's do this here. So, you said
Romans 11:22.
Yeah. Yeah. This is my final like like
my point because I I got to go soon. I I
love this. We can do this again one day
if you want. Um Paul's warning these
Romans
that kindness provided to you pro um if
you continue in his kindness otherwise
you will be cut off. The you there he's
talking to Christians
and it it's very synonymous what Jesus
said in John 15. So
yeah that's my last point and u just God
bless you and um I I'll continue
listening in the stream if you have any
more questions before I I got to head
out.
Cool. Yeah. So my response on that would
be again covenant breakers. Got to
understand covenant. The covenant is
described folks as uh Paul here uses the
example of a tree. Jesus uses a tree as
well. Um he's not giving a lecture.
Jesus isn't neither is Paul um of
horiculture.
And so if you go to John 15 where Jesus
talks about this, he talks about
branches that can be attached but not
attached to the root. That's the key.
Um, and so he uses the example of a tree
here to talk about Well, let me actually
bring this this back up. Um, he
uses a the example of a tree
um to
talk about the covenant. There's one
single tree that started with Israel,
national Israel, and then Gentiles are
engrafted into that tree. It's not a
different tree that's planted, etc. And
Paul here is talking about how some of
the natural branches, the Jews, were cut
off and foreign branches were engrafted.
But notice what he says. He says, well,
let me start actually back up here at
17.
If well, actually, no, let's go a little
bit before actually 13 because he says,
"Now I'm speaking to you Gentiles. In as
much then as I am an apostle to the
Gentiles, I magnify my ministry in order
somehow to make my fellow Jews jealous
and thus save some of them. For if their
rejection means the reconciliation of
the world, what will their acceptance
mean but life from the dead? If the
dough offered as first fruits is holy,
that's Christ. So is the whole lump. And
if the root is holy, so are the
branches. But if some of the branches
were broken off, and you, although a
wild olive chute, were grafted in among
the others, and now share in the
nourishing root of the olive tree, do
not be arrogant toward the branches. If
you remember it is not you who support
the root but the root that supports you
then you will say here actually Paul is
is using the the root um to talk about
national Israel. Don't be arrogant
toward um the the sorry I got tongue
tied there. He's using the same analogy
as Jesus in John 15. He says don't be
arrogant toward the branches. That's
telling the Gentiles not be arrogant
toward the the Jews. If you remember,
it's not you who support the root but
the root that supports you. So it's
Christ who supports us. Then you will
say branches were broken off so that I
might be grafted in. That is true. They
were broken off because of their
unbelief. But you stand fast through
faith. So do not become proud but fear.
For if God did not spare the natural
branches, neither will he spare you.
Note then the kindness and severity of
God. This is where he was quoting.
Severity toward those who have fallen,
but God's kindness to you provided you
continue in his kindness. Otherwise, you
too will be cut off. And even they, if
they do not continue in their unbelief,
will be grafted in, for God has the
power to graft them in again. For if you
were cut off from what is by nature a
wild olive tree and grafted contrary to
nature, into a cultivated olive tree,
how much more will these the natural
branches be grafted back into the same
olive tree? Two things here. This is
where people will typically point, I'm
in agreeance with this, that uh God is
going to work with national Israel again
and uh begin engrafting them, a number
of them, actually already is um back
onto the tree. But this gets back to the
point that I was saying about covenant.
And really this is a deeper discussion.
We have another SDA here that I want to
bring up. But um this really gets into a
deeper discussion that requires a lot
more around covenant. Covenant covenant.
Covenant. It's so important that
somebody can be in the covenant but not
actually in the invisible fold of God's
people. Meaning they don't actually have
a regenerative faith. They are a weed
among the or they're a tear among the
wheat. And that separation of the wheat
and the tears has not happened yet. That
will happen when Christ returns to throw
all the wicked out of his kingdom. And
so until that happens, we're going to
have a intermixing. And there are people
who will be on the tree, but they're a
dead branch. They're not actually
attached to the root. So with that said,
we've got another guest here. Hello,
Jason. Can you hear us? You are live,
sir.
Hi, Miles. Thank you for having me. Can
you hear me? Okay.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, can you if
you don't mind, can you are you able to
turn your mic down just a little bit? If
not, then I can edit the uh the mic
settings here for you. Let me turn it
down just a titch. You're a little hot.
All right. I got your mic turned down
there. What would you like to talk
about, sir? Between um the charges that
are brought, false gospel, false Jesus,
which route would you like to go?
Can I just have like a minute or two to
think?
Um, sure. We're going to have a little
bit of of dead air. Did you have a
question that was outside of those
topics because I know on that last
discussion we kind of went all over the
place and so
yeah, I I just before before I start,
you know, speaking, I just want to be
able to gather my thoughts. If you had
any questions that you'd like to hear
from an Adventist perspective,
um, I'm willing to answer those. If the
conversation is specifically about the
gospel, sure, that's fine. I just need
to know like where are we starting from
so I know how to gather my thoughts.
Did you see the beginning of the stream?
No. Um, Jason Thomas actually messaged
me like 10 minutes ago and said, "Hey,
Miles is live. Uh, do you want to join?"
and I said, "Sure, you know, why not?"
Um, so I I was I was only here for maybe
15 minutes or so.
No worries. So, we got a little bit
sidetracked in the last discussion. He
was a nice guy, though, so I I enjoyed
that. But I I want to really try and
keep it focused because the the purpose
of tonight was to essentially let
Adventists prove answering Adventism
false in the charges of the Adventist
Church having a false god and a false
gospel. So, I gave a presentation that
entailed a number of um quotes from
Ellen White. Um not saying that we need
to argue or discuss her. I'm just simply
citing what is a uh authoritative source
in the Adventist church um regarding how
she believes one is reconciled. But um
explain the gospel for us. What do you
believe the gospel is?
Sure. Um I would just take the biblical
definition from Romans 1 verse 16-17
how it says the you know the gospel is
the power of God unto salvation to
everyone who believes goes on to say
that the just are those who live by
faith right the just shall live by faith
which is basically
you know the main idea of the Protestant
Reformation just shall live by faith. So
yeah, that that's that's one aspect. Um
there's some other things there. Um but
you said it's for I'm not ashamed of the
gospel for it's the power of God of
salvation. Everyone who believes to the
Jew first and also to the Greek. That
doesn't tell me though what what is the
gospel? So he says it's the power of God
to all that believe. Believe what? What
do I have to believe in order to have
salvation?
Yeah. Um I think that's pretty
straightforward from the scripture. If
you look at 1 Corinthians 15, it says um
you know Christ died for our sins
according to the gospel. And again if
you look at Titus chapter 2 11-15 talks
about how the grace of God that brings
salvation has appeared to all men. Um if
you look at Galatians 1:4, it also
touches on different aspects of the
gospel. So I think the gospel is very
easily defined from scripture.
So 1 Corinthians 15. Yeah, 1 Corinthians
15. If you read um
No, I I I got you. I know what verses
you're talking about. We've talked about
it a lot on this channel. Um so,
question for you. What's the purpose of
the Adventist church?
Because the Adventist church because the
Adventist church claims that they have a
unique gospel that they have a a
distinct message that is the what um
your scholars have referred to people
like Herbert Douglas the fullness of the
gospel whereas the rest of us have a
truncated gospel. So, um,
what's the purpose of the Adventist
church if if that's all the gospel is?
Okay, interesting question. Sort of
steering
away from, you know, the topic of the
gospel, but like, yeah, that's a valid
question, I think. What does the
Adventist church contribute to,
you know, Protestantism, right?
Well, real quick, real quick. No, no,
I'm not I'm not asking generally. What
does the Adventist church contribute to
Protestant? This has nothing to do with
Protestantism.
Okay,
I'm saying this because we're talking
about the gospel. Would you like me to
Would you like me to bring up You can go
to answering Adventism.com, folks. You
can type in the search bar up top
everlasting gospel. It'll be the first
card that will pop up for you. What is
the everlasting gospel of Revelation
14:6? And you will see that there are
multiple sources that are linked from
your own church's um well, publications.
You've got some Review and Herald
articles. We've looked at other ones on
here over the the gamut of the 1930s all
the way up to the '9s to the 70s to the
201s. Um, it's the consistent message
that other people have a truncated
gospel. The Adventist church was raised
up by God because they're preaching a
message that was not preached by the
apostles, the early church, or the
Protestant reformers because it's a
distinct message for people right before
the end of the world and it's labeled as
the fullness of the gospel.
So
what you just said in 1 Corinthians 15,
your scholars are claiming is not the
fullness of the gospel.
There's more to it than that.
Yeah. To clarify, I haven't read like
what every single Adventist scholar has
said. I'm just giving you what I believe
as an Adventist who grew up in the
Adventist church. Obviously, I I didn't
make, you know, just a little background
about me. I didn't make Adventism my own
until I was about 17 or 18, even though
I grew up in the Adventist church. Um, I
do have my bachelor's in religious
studies from an Adventist school. Um, so
I do know some things, but I'm not a
like a wide red scholar. I could just
give you how I understand the gospel as
an Adventist who grew up in Adventist
home.
But I could I could try I could try to
tackle your question if I may. Well, the
only reason I ask is because I'm not
necessarily here to to the title of the
stream tonight and everything in the the
presentation I gave earlier is about the
official organ. I understand there's all
sorts of Adventists that believe all
sorts of stuff. Just look at the
comments in my videos and I've talked
with thousands of Adventists at this
point
and you're going to hear all sorts of
stuff,
but we should look at the official
source materials. And this channel,
Answering Adventism, is not about
individual SDAs and what they
individually believe. It's about what
does the official organization put forth
and state. So I'm just citing them not
to do an appeal to authority but to show
you this is what if we can't go to the
SDA church themselves the GC the
official publications like the Adventist
Review uh the Pioneers Ellen White then
I don't know how you can even define
anything about Adventism and have any
sort of concrete or clear thing. So I'm
just citing them to simply say they're
disagreeing with what you're saying. 1
Corinthians 15 is not the fullness of
the gospel. That's only part of the
gospel. What's on screen is the fullness
of your guys' gospel. Your three angels
messages, which includes the
investigative judgment, leaving apostate
Protestantism and Babylon, coming to the
Seventh Advenist Church and being a part
of God's last day remnant before the the
wrath of God is poured out, which has a
a corresponding effect of the Seventh
Day Sabbath observance and and receiving
the seal of God, not the mark of the
beast. the health message, which yes,
Ellen White said is the right arm of the
gospel and has to be believed alongside
everything else because it's going to be
a part of demonstrating that you're fit
for the new earth. Uh you have to
believe Ellen White's writings, the
state of the dead with conditional
immortality. You've got young earth
creationism. You've got victory over
sin, which is a prepared people and
righteousness by faith, which we've
discussed on this channel before and is
redefined, etc. But all of this stuff is
lumped in as your guys' gospel message.
I understand that. And I think it's
easy, at least with the Adventist
message, to look at a long list like
this and pick something out and say,
"See, you guys believe some weird stuff
if you
No, I'm just saying like I can
understand your perspective that if you
were to show someone who knows hardly
anything about Adventism this list and
if they heard you say the things that
you're saying,
I could understand why somebody could
come come aside with the idea that
Adventists are weird when it's put the
way that you put it.
I gota stop you. I gotta real quick,
man. I got to stop you right there
because
um Sorry. I'm just I'm trying to be to
be patient and stuff. You're a nice guy.
Um and so I have to constantly war with
that just because again I've had these
conversations so many times and so it's
easy to to become short-ended. you're a
nice guy. So again, I'm not trying to um
lose my patience on you or anything, but
the reason I brought this up, man, is
not to say SDAs are weird. None of that.
The point is none of this is the gospel.
You've added to the gospel. And we read
earlier, Paul says, "I'm astonished
writing to the churches at Galatia when
people were creeping in unawares, trying
to spy out their freedom that they had
in Christ, and they were changing the
gospel message, the power of God into
salvation. They were changing that." And
he says,"I am astonished
that you were so quickly deserting him."
This is him laying the foundation for
the whole epistle. That you're deserting
him who called you in the grace of
Christ and are turning to a different
gospel.
Not that there is another one, but there
are some who trouble you and want to
distort the gospel of Christ. That means
a number of things. There are false
gospels out there. Simply saying the
name gospel or the word gospel, that
doesn't tell us whether this is a
different gospel or or not.
He says there's not another gospel. So
they're like your scholars are saying
but well we have the fullness of the
gospel and they have a limited that's
the word Herbert Douglas uses or the
phrase he uses a limited gospel. The
Adventist church is restoring the
fullness of the gospel the everlasting
gospel. Well, no. Paul says there's only
one gospel. There's no limited and then
full. He says, "Even if we or an angel,
that would include three angels from
heaven should preach to you a gospel
contrary to the one we preach to you,
let him be accursed."
People who are preaching false gospels
are cursed. If you add anything to the
gospel, you are cursed. This all is an
addition to the gospel. None of this
stuff is the power of God to salvation.
I see what you're saying.
You don't have to believe investigative
judgment. You don't have to join the
Adventist church or keep seven days
seven day Sabbath observance or the
health message. None of this stuff is
the power of God to salvation. Yet your
church is teaching that this is the
fullness of the gospel added on top of
what you mentioned earlier.
Yeah, that's interesting. Um,
I've spoken to several
Baptist friends on Discord and you know
I have Baptist friends in real life and
we talk about the gospel sometimes and I
noticed that in our communication
sometimes as I try to explain the gospel
as I understand it. They come away a
little confused and part of this is due
to us having different understandings of
certain theological words that we use.
Other times it's just I intend to
communicate one idea as I understand it
in my mind but it just comes out
differently. When it comes to the gospel
though, the way I try to approach it,
especially, you know, within the context
of the amethyst message, yes, Revelation
14 6 to 12 is definitely, you know, the
heart of our message, the three angels
message, the gospel, right? That first
angel has the everlasting gospel to
preach unto all the world. But I find it
so much more helpful to unpack the
gospel by coming through the book of
First John. So, is it okay as I unpack
some of your questions that we go to
first John chapter 4?
Um, sure.
Yeah. Because I think once this is
understood,
well, my pastor just got done preaching
every verse of First John uh three weeks
ago. So,
Oh, wonderful. I bet it was a wonderful
message.
Yeah. 1 John chapter 4 is a portion of
scripture that is very dear to me and I
think sometimes
especially as Adventists sometimes as
Adventist
um we miss out on the beauty and the
simplicity of the gospel by not every
single Adventist mind you but there are
certain pockets of Adventism that focus
way too much on the law and the works of
the law and it sort of seems to seem
like it's legalistic. where it leaves
out Christ where if Christ was the
center of every single message and he
was the all in all then the beauty of
the Adventist truth would be clearly
seen but we're going to start in verse
16 if that's okay
sure
because this ties in very nicely to the
first angel's message which has to do
with the investigative judgment right so
do you want me to read or should you
read
Sure go ahead
okay so 1 John 4 Verse 16 it says, "And
we have known and believed the love that
God has to us. God is love, and he that
dwelleth in love dwelleth in God and God
in him."
Now notice that John uses two particular
words here in verse 16. He uses the word
know and he uses the word believe. And I
think for a lot of people, because I've
been in this situation myself, a lot of
people know about the gospel. A lot of
people know that about 2,000 years ago,
somebody named Jesus died on the cross,
made atonement for sins, etc. A lot of
people know that. Like for a lot of
people, that is factual knowledge.
But you really start to experience the
beauty of the gospel when you get to the
believe part, right? Because it's not
enough to know. It's you also need to
believe, right? You need to internalize
that beautiful love of the gospel
demonstrated by Jesus hanging on the
cross for yourself. Because how many
times have you heard people say in the
Adventist church even that you know like
I don't think I'm going to heaven. you
know, I just so sinful, so dirty, so
messed up. Like to me, it's almost as if
there are people who know about the
gospel, but they don't believe the
gospel. They don't believe the love of
the gospel actually applies to them and
their sinfulness and their dirtiness and
their wretchedness. And so I think verse
16 is where the gospel really gets
unpacked to make that distinction
between knowing and believing because
once you know and believe the gospel
then you don't need to fear the
investigative judgment because of verse
17 right herein is our love made perfect
that we may have what? Boldness in the
day of judgment. If you have boldness in
the day of judgment why would you be
afraid of the investigative judgment?
Well, there's a number of problematic
assumptions here. Um, just because this
is called word association fallacy. Um,
the day of judgment here is not talking
about the investigative judgment. Um,
that's you're seeing the word judgment.
So, you're attaching 1844. And you you
think John was talking about 1844 there,
but there's going to be a judgment that
starts in 1844.
That that's not what I said. I said, why
would we need to be afraid of the
investigative judgment? Because like
there is the verse that says he has
appointed a day where he will judge the
world in like right.
Yeah. Yeah. Acts 17. Um but again that
again you're just looking for the word
judgment and then you're porting a bunch
of things in there. But my man, we have
to take another step back. Um
okay, no problem. Because
because we still haven't nailed down
what you're you're pointing here. So the
gospel is God's love. That's that's just
it. And you're saying I I agree with
you, by the way, that you have to have
more than what theologians would call an
essentiary faith. The devil has an
essentiary faith. He has the mental
knowledge of the creator. That's not
actually what a true faith is. I I agree
with you in that regard. But we still
haven't nailed down what the gospel
exactly is regarding the Adventist
message because it's an addition of
things. And nothing here in in First
John supports the idea that since you
just mentioned only the one that the
investigative judgment is a part of the
gospel.
The gospel is the power of God into
salvation to all that believe it. So
yes, there is a true belief and a false
fake belief like James talks about in
James chapter 2. I'm in agreeance with
that. But what is it that a person
believes that is the power of God to
salvation? That when they when a person
does truly believe, not just with their
lips, but does truly believe. What is it
that they're truly believing? You think
it's that they're believing that there's
an investigative judgment? They have to
leave an apostate church and come join
the remnant adventist church. They have
to observe the 7th day Sabbath to
receive the seal. They have to observe
the health message. Believe in Ellen
White's writings. You think all that
stuff is the power of God into
salvation.
I never said that conversation.
No. No. Right. Question mark. I'm I'm
saying it as a as a question mark, which
is kind of rhetorical because the point
is is that that's not the gospel. That
that and that's precisely the point of
why we're doing this tonight. It's not
for you to to to
come and and I'm not faulting you for
this. I'm just explaining. Um, it's not
for Adventists to come and and try their
darnest and their best to explain to me
um, you know, why this isn't weird or
the the sort of logical dots. I I get
it, my man. I was raised in Adventism.
My dad's an Adventist pastor still to
this day. Um, I went to Adventist
schools throughout my whole life. I've
studied this systematically. I I I've
got it. I understand that from inside
the system is is consistent and they've
done a really good job of of coming up
with that. but it's not dealing with the
the primary thing that's in view
tonight, which is actually um this. So,
I want to bring up a a document here for
you and ask if you agree with this. This
is the review and herald
1934. There's a number of other of
these. Like I said, folks, these are on
answering adventism.com. You can access
all of this information under the tab
under the Q&A section of the Gospel.
Just look for the question regarding um
the everlasting what is the everlasting
gospel of Revelation 14:6. And notice
what it says here. This movement with
which we are connected stands for
certain great fundamental truths. The
existence of God, the inspiration of the
holy scriptures, salvation alone through
the vicarious sacrifice of the Lord
Jesus, repentance, regeneration, and the
gift of righteousness by faith. All
these things which we have to end up
defining to get into what they're really
saying here. the work of the Holy
Spirit, the immutability of God's law,
the binding claims of the Bible Sabbath,
the priestly ministry of Christ in the
heavenly sanctuary, the investigative
judgment now going on, the soon coming
of Christ to take his children home, the
doctrine of spiritual gifts, the
manifestation of the gift of prophecy in
the remnant church, life only in Christ,
Christian temperance, and other leading
important biblical doctrines. These
great truths constitute the everlasting
gospel message for this time.
To the seventh advenist church has been
committed this message. The everlasting
gospel was preached by Noah, by Abraham,
by Paul and Peter, and by all the
prophets and apostles of past ages. It
was preached in the setting appropriate
to their day. This is getting into
present truth. We cannot preach this
gospel message as Noah preached it or as
Paul or Luther gave it. It is for us to
preach it in the setting of God's great
three-fold message of Revelation 14.
And then they go on to talk about how
Luther preached this in his setting. And
we're but really all it is is a vehicle
to weasle in. None of the apostles, none
of the reformers preached anything that
I just had on screen. None of them. You
could maybe argue that some of the
reformers talked about conditional
immortality, etc. But none of them
attach that as the gospel. That if a
person doesn't believe this, they're
going to be damned.
None of this stuff is the gospel. That's
not what Revelation 14:6 is talking
about. The the everlasting gospel in
Revelation 14:6 is the exact same gospel
as we just saw that Paul was talking
about because there is only one gospel.
And Jesus is the one, Paul says in
Galatians 1:12, who revealed that gospel
message to the apostles and then they
took that message and it's been handed
down to us today in holy scripture and
also I would argue orally to some
degree, but it's been handed down to us
today such that we can believe the exact
same message. Jesus didn't reveal a
different gospel to John that he'd
already, you know, he already re
revealed the gospel to John as an
apostle. But then in the apocalypse,
he's revealing to him a different
gospel, which would be a cursed gospel.
And uh
it has this sort of like morph like
character where well in the 1800s now
all of a sudden Revelation 14 has this
unique and special meaning as if it
didn't apply to the first, second,
third, fourth, etc. centuries.
I see. I have a few questions for you.
Who wrote this article? cuz you
mentioned that it was published in 1934.
I believe this is after the death of
Ellen White. So, who's the author?
Um, I don't know if this specific one
here. I just know it's from the Review
and Herald. And I have an archive of
Review and Herald papers. Um, but this
is definitely not I mean, if you'd like,
I can bring up some other ones. Is JL
Scheler is he enough? Arguably the
longest I don't know if somebody's beat
his record now, but argu arguably the
longest uh evangelist in Adventist
history.
Right. The the only thing is like um you
know when you mentioned review and
herald right the first thing my mind
goes to is like the Ella White
publications that she wrote. Um I
wouldn't take this particular article
just because of the date that it was
written as authoritative. Um
well this isn't the only one I mean I
mean I just pulled up one. Would you
like me to I can pull up about 10 more
of these for you? Same thing.
They're all saying it. I can go all the
way up to 1994 with Robert Fulenberg who
was the president at the time. I mean,
my point was is that this is the
consistent thing, man. Like, this isn't
a this isn't a oneoff.
Yeah, I understand where you're coming
from. My my point is is that this isn't
something that Ellen White wrote.
Correct.
Okay. So, if I bring up an Ellen White
quote, before we go there, if I bring up
an Ellen White quote that says the same
thing, are you going to accept it?
I mean, we would have to look at the
context and things like that because I
know Ella White has written very
beautiful things about the gospel. For
example, and signs of the times,
December 30, 1889, she says, "The blood
of Christ is the eternal antidote for
sin." So, so right, if you mix in a
little bit of rat poison into a pie, it
poisons the whole pie. you can find all
sorts of of loveydovey sort of stuff and
I talk about that a lot on this channel
as well that just because she said
something good that doesn't now override
the fact that she may have said
something damnably heretical.
I you know and again I understand your
concern and I think you know honestly
this is why I appreciate it when people
try to you know poke at Adventism and
things because it does two things. One,
it makes us understand or like it makes
us dig as to why we believe what we
believe. And the second thing is because
I believe that the truth loses nothing
by investigation.
So me talking with you shouldn't
produce anything bad, right? If
anything, it should make us both come
away with new glimpses of truth.
Sure. Um I I think that that can
generally be true. I think that you can
learn things from people that you don't
necessarily agree with. Um I think I
think that that's healthy to do. Um but
what we're talking about here, man, is a
life ordeath issue. This is not some
sort of
I understand. Yeah. Because from your
perspective,
if what we're doing is adding to the
gospel, then we're cursed. And if what
we're doing is a cursed ministry, then
what we're doing is perpetuating death,
right? So, you definitely have cause for
concern if you think that how we're
approaching
spreading the gospel is incorrect. And
if you have questions, like, you know,
I'm all for trying to answer your
questions to the best of my ability.
No, I I just um I don't necessarily have
any questions other than um
you know that we we haven't my mind
hasn't been changed tonight, which is
really the the ultimate challenge to to
prove that you know I regularly hear I'm
not saying necessarily you have said
this, but I get hundreds of comments a
week and I hear constantly from people
that um you don't know what you're
talking about. You that's not true. Um,
so the purpose of tonight was to openly
propose that, okay, come and come and
change my mind then and explain to me
how this is not incorrect. Well, here's
a quote from Ellen White man saying, and
again, if you want another one after
this, we'll bring up another one after
this. Okay,
sure.
Same same paper, Review and Herald, July
7, 1891.
And if you'd like, you can send me your
if you'd like, you can send me your
email.
I will happily share with you. I have a
document of over 120 pages with all the
stuff categorized by section and topic
and you can look over the list yourself
and see all of them yourself and you can
go check out the context. You tell me if
I'm taking stuff out of context.
Yeah.
So she says she says here's the patience
of the saints which she's quoting here
from your guys's favorite passage.
Yeah.
Revelation 14.
The third angel is represented as
following the first and second angels
and crying with a loud voice. If any man
worship the beast in his image, and
receive his mark in his forehead or in
his hand, the same shall drink of the
wine of the wrath of God, which is
poured out without mixture into the cup
of his indignation. Here is the patience
of the saints. Here are they that keep
the commandments of God in the faith of
Jesus. Shall not we who read these
threatenings, and who believe the word
of God give the warning to a world lying
in darkness?
The angels are represented as flying in
the midst of heaven, uttering a solemn
proclamation. Their voices are not heard
by the inhabitants of the earth, saved
through the people who carry forward the
work as the messengers of God. Those who
search the scriptures understand the
messages given by the angels and take up
the cry proclaiming the warning to the
world. The three messages for this time
are of most solemn import and it is of
the greatest consequence to those
consequence to those who hear whether or
not they act upon the light given. God
calls upon his faithful watchmen who see
the danger and lift up the cry. The
morning cometh and also the night. It is
the work of every soul who understands
the Bible truth for this time again
present truth to unite his voice with
the messenger in proclaiming the message
in pushing the triumphs of the cross.
The truths must be presented in its
simplicity and laid out in clear lines.
We are in no case to hide our light
under a bushel as if ashamed of it. We
have nothing of which to be ashamed. The
commandments of God are to be honored
above the traditions and commandments of
men. We just read this thing earlier.
So, we read the previous next three
paragraphs earlier, which is my my
commendation that I gave for Adventists
to take Ellen White up on our words. So,
if you want to see that, we read these
three paragraphs earlier. Um, and this
is literally just the right before that.
Again, it's saying the same thing that
the article was saying is that this is a
present truth message for this time. It
cannot be preached the same way, which I
have a video coming out in a couple
weeks. I encourage you to watch it. I'm
looking at a ton of these sources.
again, Robert Fulenberg, GC president at
the time, Ellen White, um JL Scheler,
James White, uh George Knight, you know,
are these people authoritative enough
sources?
Herbert Douglas, I mean, household name,
Adventist household name. If there
aren't other sources, man, outside of
this, let me know what they are. What's
a what's a higher higher source than
this? They're all saying the same thing,
I'm telling you. And like I said, you'll
see. And if you want, I can bring that
one up for If you want to look at Robert
Fulenberg,
this is in the '9s. All the way up to
the 90s, they're saying the same thing,
Adventist Review,
etc.
So, so my what I'm a little confused
about right now is what are you taking
issue with in this particular Ellen
White writing? Because so far,
everything you read it it sounds okay to
me. Is it the fact that she says like
that that distinction between how Noah
preached and how we're preaching? Is
that the issue? I I just want to be
clear. If you could just put into one or
two sentences where is the
No, no, you just asked
what we read that quote earlier from the
review and Herald from 1930 and you said
to not take that as official because we
don't know who wrote it and it was after
the time of Ellen White's death. So I
just brought up a quote here to show you
she's saying the same thing here
that the message is a present truth
message.
It's something for this time for this
time. for this. So, I was just showing
you I can bring up 15 more things where
they're all talking about the same thing
that this message is a present truth
message for the time being.
It was not preached the same way by the
apostles. And when I do this video in a
couple weeks, people are going to see
that
Robert Fulenberg and J Scheler give us
just gold on this subject to be put it
frankly that they they shoot it
completely straight.
Can I read the the the quote for you? Do
you mind? Uh yeah, just one sec if I
could ask you a question because like uh
I don't want to get like you know
sidetracked or anything but when it
comes to present truth um let's
hypothetically you know go back to
Noah's time would it have been fair or
unjust of Noah to leave out
the truth about the importance of
getting unto the ark.
Was Noah preaching the investigative
judgment?
No, that's that that wasn't the
question. Like let's say I'm respond I
know I'm responding with a question
because that that essentially gives my
answer test
because Noah was preaching the same
message that people are preaching today.
Repent and believe
because the day of judgment because
judgment is coming which in that case
was the flood and you guys will you
oftentimes as well the video that's
coming out actually is about present
truth. So, um, you'll, you know, you
guys will point to Jo Jonah and Nineveh.
A number of things I'd say is that those
stories are not something for us to look
at to try and deduce these sorts of
things. It is typologically
foreshadowing something of um, in this
case judgment and people being spared in
in the ark, which is sign of covenant
and being in Christ, etc. Um, it's not
Noah was Noah was not preaching novel
doctrine
regarding
well he was preaching a judgment and so
we're preaching a judgment and since
we're both preaching a judgment
generally speaking
it's it's ultimately the same. Well, no
it's not. Noah was not preaching an
investigative judgment which is the
judgment the SDA church is trying to say
is the present truth judgment.
Okay. Um, I would take issue with what
you said as to, you know, how Noah's
story is not really relevant for us now
just because of what Romans 15 vers
I didn't say that. I I didn't say that.
I didn't say it's not relevant for us
now. What I said was is or if I did, I
misspoke. What I was saying is that the
story of Noah is not to teach us an idea
of uh present truth. essentially that
that's not the purpose of so looking to
Noah to say well
see he preached a message for his day
and because we can't preach to get on
the ark today that means that the truth
is uh well I'll read you here's how
James White defines it this is from the
present truth volume one July 1849 he
says
and I should say like there there are
going to be parallels but that's not
like you know today's message is not go
build an ark of gopherwood right like
there are specific elements that are
only for Noah and his time.
Right. Right. But
the parallels are what people are
drawing from from Noah's story in order
to make a point that, you know, there's
a certain time to say a certain thing,
right? That's I think that's really
where the comparison comes from. Not so
much, oh, we're doing it because Noah's
doing it.
Well, no, no, I know that. I know that.
My my entire point with all that though
is to say that looking to the story of
Noah to try and essentially affirm
present truth which James White defines
it this way. Present truth volume 1 July
1849 in Peter's time there was present
truth or truth applicable to that
present time.
You said the church
you said this is review and herald 1849.
No no no no. James White the present
truth.
Oh
volume volume one July 1849.
The present truth. He says in Peter's
time there was truth or truth applicable
to the present time. This is after he's
falsely quoted uh 2 Peter 1:12,
which is what they typically try to
point to, which is actually saying the
exact opposite of this idea of present
truth. Um but nevertheless, that's how
he essentially defines it.
The Adventist church will then point to
that to say, well, and I've heard this,
which is why I'm saying this. They'll
point to that and say, see, it's not
that we're preaching a different
message. We were both we're both
preaching a judgment. For example, Jo
Noah was preaching a judgment. So are
we. So therefore, that's the thing that
ties all this, you know, consistently.
But then when you look at the judgment,
well, no, it's the point of all of this,
man, is that that's not the gospel. It's
adding to the gospel. That's not the
gospel. Again, Robert S. Fulenberg,
Everpresent Truth, a message from the
president, Adventist Review, October 26,
1995, page 32. Everyone, you can go look
these up in the archive. All this stuff
is online. Quote, "As 7th Day
Adventists, we believe we have a present
truth message found in the proclamation
of the three angels of Revelation 14. We
particularly note the message of the
third angel with its warning about those
who worship the beast in contrast to the
in contrast to those who keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus." This is a distinct message
for a distinct time, our time in fact,
which is why we deem it present truth.
Close quote. JL Scheler, God's present
truth for this present time. Adventist
Review and Sabbath Herald, May 5th,
1932. Quote, "In harmony with this idea
that this message, three angels
messages, is limited to the period
between 1844 and the end, we find that
no one prior to 1844 had ever claimed to
have given this three-fold message.
Neither Luther nor Calvin nor Knox,
Wesley, Alexander, Campbell, or any of
the other great lights of those times
set up the claim that they were doing
this predicated work of Revelation
14:6-12. If this work had been done by
any of them, they'd have surely known
it. Close quote. Final quote. Same guy.
Next paragraph in his his same paper. JL
Scheler, God's Present Truth for the
Present Time, Adventist Review and
Sabbath Herald, May 5th, 1932, page 8.
This prophecy
of revelation 14:6-14 does not and
cannot refer to any proclamation of the
gospel in the days of the apostles, the
early Christian fathers, or the
reformers of the 16th, 17th, or 18th
centuries. It is strictly a last day
message applicable to those who lived
just before the return of Christ. Close
quote.
It is over and over and over, my man.
Jason, I I appreciate you. You're a nice
guy. We have um another person in Q
here. It's been fun going back and forth
for for quite some time. Again, you're
you're a nice guy. But
I would challenge you, my man, to really
think about the fact that um there's
only one gospel.
And if you are clinging to these sorts
of things, going to church on Saturday,
health message, investigative judgment,
and you think that these things are the
power of God under salvation, you are
going to be sorely, sorely, sorely
mistaken. And that is why answering
Adventism exists. It's not to destroy
people. It's not to belittle people.
It's not to make fun of people. But this
is a serious issue. This is not like,
uh, well, should we have drums in
church, etc. And again, you know, if
we're being honest, the Adventist church
would say the same thing. I'm an
apostate. I'm lost. I need to get back
on the ark. I'm drowning out in the
water. My only hope is to, um,
essentially come back and and and all
that sort of stuff. And, you know, I I
want Adventists to be honest about that
stuff and not, you know, beat her on the
bush.
Yeah. For the record, I wouldn't say
that about you personally. I think
Well, that's fine. The official the
official sources would,
right? So, and that's what you know the
prophetic prophetic authority would,
right? The churches like you know our
church leaders shouldn't be like the end
all be all of what's said like because
the church is made up of individuals
everybody thinks
but but Ellen White is supposedly um
precious rays of light from the throne
room. She never wrote a single sentence
of heresy. Her words in her books are
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord.
We've gone over this over and over and
over on here. So, this is God speaking.
And she has said and we've looked at
countless quotes, my man. We're not
going to do that right now, but we we've
looked at countless quotes before where
your church's official source materials.
While I understand that you may not say
that personally, and I get Adventists
all the time that say that, "No, no, no.
I don't think you're lost. I think you
genuinely love the Lord." Um, well,
that's inconsistent with with official
Adventist teaching. Official Adventist
teaching says that I'm lost. I don't
have the fullness of the gospel. I've
been revealed this light and have
rejected it, which I don't believe it's
actually light, which is why I've
rejected it. But nevertheless, because
I've rejected that, I have rejected the
light that I'm going to be accountable
to. And unless I were to repent of that
and come back to the Adventist church, I
don't have I don't have hope because I'm
a part of Babylon supposedly knowingly
now. Um my prayers are an abomination to
God. Um because I reject the
investigative judgment. I reject all the
the points that we we just had on here.
Um I don't accept any of of these. Um,
and so by that standard, they would 100%
say that um, I'm lost. But we're going
to do these again. Um, so come back.
Like I said, you're a nice guy. So was
the previous guy. Um, you guys are
welcome back to come on any anytime.
Sure. When's the next one? I'll put it
in my comments.
Um, I keep an eye on the channel. I
don't know exactly right now because my
schedule kind of uh I have some other
people that are kind of up in limbo
right now and so I kind of work around
their schedules, but it won't be super
long. It'll be uh it'll be within the
next month. Um I'd like to do these
weekly if I could, but I just I am other
things. I just don't have uh I don't
have enough time. So
So right right before I go, I just want
to ask you one question just so I could
sort of know where you stand and like
future conversations. So do you affirm
or not believe in the continuing gift of
prophecy?
Uh no, I'm a I'm a cessationist.
Cessationist. Okay, good to know. Thank
you.
Yep. Yep. No problem. Bye.
All right, Jason was a a nice guy.
Thanks for coming on, Jason. Got our
next one here. This will be the the last
one, folks. Uh Tedla, thank you for
being here. You are live. Can you hear
us? I see that your mic is muted. Oh,
it's unmuted now. Welcome. And uh what
topic of the two would you like to talk
about? Would you like to talk about the
gospel of Adventism or the Jesus of
Adventism?
Well, I did put a question in the chat.
I was just trying to find out if you do
screen sharing.
Uh, I I do. Um, first though, I I I'm
not able to see all the questions.
Sorry, I don't have the I have a number
of monitors up here and I kind of have
some other operation stuff that I have
up so I don't have the the chat up. Um,
is the question to do with the topic for
tonight? It's just one slide that's
trying to sum up everything.
Right.
One slide it so I could I guess navigate
from there.
Right. Right. Do you want to talk about
the gospel of Adventism or the Jesus?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's the gospel. It's
it's everything basically, but it's just
one slide I need to show on the screen
if that's okay.
Yeah. So, if you you can click the
button at the bottom that says present
and click uh share screen and select the
the screen or wherever it wherever it
may be.
Uh I'm not familiar with this. Do I go
to settings?
No, just hit present down at the bottom
and there'll be a and when the little
menu pops up it'll say share screen.
When I look at the bottom, I see mic,
cam, chat, more, and then leave. I don't
see present.
Oh, interesting. Um, I'm not sure. You
might be on a device that is not Are you
on a phone?
I'm on a phone.
Yeah. So, no, you have to be on a
desktop to be able to uh to be able to
share. So, um that would be why it's
it's it's not able. Um, what aspect of
um, well, we'll just we'll start with
this. Um, what is the gospel?
Well, I was gonna I was going to use the
sanctuary to sort of show you uh, what
the gospel is. I don't I mean, I could
say it right now, but maybe people don't
have a picture of it in their head to Do
you have a picture of Well, it's okay.
Anyways, um
yeah, I know I know about all seven
steps and the labor and the the basin
and yeah, the camp.
Okay. So, okay. So, I'll just if you
could picture it in your mind. Um
there's like three doors in the
sanctuary. Three doors. Like there's one
that enters the outer court.
There's one that after that that enters
the holy place. And then there's one
that enters the most holy place. Right?
And so the Bible says, "Thy way, oh God,
is in the sanctuary." So we derived our
gospel and everything that we teach from
the sanctuary. Although it is said that,
you know, LG White confirmed certain
things along the way of them studying.
It's the sanctuary is where we get
everything from. So through that first
door, if we're talking about the gospel,
um it's the Holy Spirit that brings you
to acknowledge Christ, right? And so we
have the altar of sacrifice. At the
altar of sacrifice, it just represents
the fact that Jesus died. And so the
first step in our Christian walk is to
first acknowledge Christ as our Lord and
Savior. Right? That's the first thing we
do.
That's I know we don't I guess the Old
Testament they teach about circumcision
but Paul talks about the circumcision of
the heart. So we have to first accept
the Lord in our heart as our personal
Lord and Savior. And it's the Holy
Spirit that brings us to that
acknowledgment of Jesus Christ the
Savior. Right? And then we have to truly
be circumcised in the heart. The next
thing um well the fire that consumes the
sacrifice
um also can represent the fact that the
Holy Spirit is the one that consumes the
sins in our lives because the first
thing that we do we have to die to self.
self has to die, right? That's how we
truly are circumcised in the heart
because um circumcision involves cutting
off the the the the flesh, the the
foreskin.
So, we have to be guided by the spirit
and not the flesh, right? Our six senses
will misguide us. The Bible says that
our hearts are deceitfully and
desperately wicked. So, we have to have
that. And the next step you see is the
labor of water, right? Um
representing the fact that we have to be
born again. The Bible says we have to be
born of the water and the spirit. Um
when we're born of the spirit, we choose
to follow the spirit. And then
baptism
is to be is where we we're born of the
water. So in baptism there's a symbolism
where we go down into the water, right?
So you experience the death, burial, and
resurrection. When we go down into the
water, that represents the fact that we
are dead. Um
we no longer live. What comes up out of
the water is Jesus Christ. And that's
why that go that ties into what we
believe on death. Death is asleep. And
so when we surrender our lives to to to
Christ, self has to die. All of our
selfish desires that are outside of
Christ has to remain basically dead in
that pool. And when we become a new
creature in Christ, it's us living
through the Holy Spirit. So because we
accept Christ
as our personal Lord and Savior,
everything in the outer court it
represents the first step which is
justification.
Um because before that we are under
condemnation, right? We all have sinned
and fallen short. We're under the
condemnation of the law. So it's Christ
that justifies us, right? So basically
Christ right there delivers us from the
penalty of sin. And so the next step we
would enter into is sanctification,
right? And so if you even look at what
happened in the sanctuary when the
priests before
they they would have to deal with I
guess the sacrifice and and at the labor
they would have to cleanse themselves
from the vestigages of death. So they
would have to um just like we have to
cleanse ourselves from spiritual death.
And the priest wore a white garment
representing the robe of righteousness.
And we have to be clothed by the robe of
righteousness before we enter into the
holy place which represents holy living.
Right? It's it's the it's the Holy
Spirit that helps us when we in in in
the step of sanctification, we are
delivered from the power of sin. That's
where the Holy Spirit comes in and gives
us power to live a holy life. That's
very important. Um, and there's so many
details of the sanctuary. It's it's it's
deep, but I'm just going over some main
things. You have the table of showbread
that represents the word of God. And um
you you know you had six and six
representing the 66 books of the Bible.
It it goes into more details, but
anyways, I'm going to I'm not going to
try to make it so long. So in our
Christian walk, we have to read our
Bibles daily. All these things were done
daily. We have to read our Bibles so we
can grow in Christ. And the the altar of
intense represents the prayers that we
have to basically when it says pray
without ceasing in the Bible, it's just
having an attitude of prayer, right? Um
and it's the the incense representing,
you know, Christ's righteousness that
ascends with our prayers when we're
praying to God. And then we have the the
manura, the golden lampstand. It
represents the fact that we need to let
our light shine by exercising and
sharing our faith. So all these three
things were to be done on a daily basis.
Uh and and and that's how it is. That's
how we are sanctified. It's it's it's
spiritual growth. And that's why it's
hard to say like I believe that there's
wheat and tears in every church. Do you
agree with that?
Um well
there's a wheaten church and every
church which
it does depends what depends what you
mean by every church. Um every church
well no because there's completely false
churches and it's kind of a
No, I'm talking about the individual the
individuals in each church.
Yeah. No, there no there there's not
saved people necessarily in every single
every single church. There are false
branches. There are branches that are
completely lost.
No, no. Okay.
Okay. So, what I'm trying to say is we
have to live up to the light that we
have. We faith comes by hearing. When we
read the word of God is God speaking to
us. And so, and when we pray to God is
us speaking to God. And we have to
practice what we preach. So, when we get
a conviction from the word of God, then
we live it out. And you know, we spread
the gospel and plus we have to live the
gospel. We can't contradict ourselves.
And you know,
when you're living in that holy life,
if you look at the the the tent that
there was three layers. Um the first
layer there was the design.
I'm gonna I'm gonna
Okay. Okay. I'm going too far.
Okay. Go ahead. Go. I just wanted to
share the gospel. Yeah. Go ahead. Well,
I understand that you're um sharing for
the audience what not because I I know
all this. I I've Yep. I know. Um I'm
going to be doing a series of videos on
all the all seven steps and the whole
sanctuary system. Um so I'm aware of all
that, but a number of things I have to
say because there was a lot there.
There's no way we're going to be able to
get to all this. We're already
I know. I'm just briefing it.
Can I just finish the brief the brief
part of it? I'll just go straight to the
end.
Sure. if you go straight to the end
because again there was so much there
that we're not going to be able to get
to nearly
Yes, I know that. I know that I and I I
respect your time. So sanctification is
a lifetime, right?
And then and and so sanctification is us
being delivered from the power of sin
through the Holy Spirit. The final step
is us being delivered from the presence
of sin. That's when when Christ comes
again and basically we get our immortal
bodies and we're delivered from the
power of the presence of sin and we're
we go to Christ to heaven. So those are
three steps in in in in our w um and
there's so much more about the
sprinkling of the blood. The the law is
the standard. That's why they sprinkled.
Okay. Okay. I'm gonna cut you off. I'm
gonna cut you off. Yeah, go ahead.
There there there's a lot. And
this kind of
No, you're good. This this kind of
speaks to to my point though of of why
I'm doing all this.
Um so I'm going to say quite a bit here
because again I I got to respond to to
everything that you said. So sit tight.
Um
the concern is because everything that
you gave Tedda is a jumbled mess for the
average person. And what I mean by that
is the average person in the SDA church
cannot describe these things. And yet
what you're describing to me is what
you're calling the gospel.
Paul says, and we've looked at this
earlier. You may not have been here.
For I'm not ashamed of the gospel. It's
the power of God for salvation to
everyone who believes, to the Jew first,
also to the Greek.
Paul did not use the sanctuary system
the way the Adventist church is to
describe salvation.
Nowhere in the New Testament is the
sanctuary service described other than
the book of Hebrews to draw drastic
differences in a compare and contrast
throughout the entire book of what makes
Jesus in the new covenant better than
the old covenant. So one modeling the
gospel off of the sanctuary system when
really you shouldn't be looking at
yourself. We talked about this earlier.
This is the problem with anthropocentric
theological systems where you read
yourself into all these things. Well,
when I see the labor, I'm supposed to
see myself there. when I see this, you
know, I'm supposed to see myself there.
When in reality, no. When you look at
the showbread, you should be seeing
Jesus, the bread of life. When you look
at the manora, you should be looking at
Jesus, the light of the world. You
shouldn't be looking at these things to
see um well, this is actually laying out
typologically the steps of of salvation
going through this whole sanctuary model
because the the famous Psalm 77 was
quoted, "Thy way, O Lord, is in the
sanctuary." That's a bad rendering.
That's the King James. The King James is
the only one that renders it that way.
But also to think that the psalter was
saying um what he's talking about is
salvation is through these seven steps
in the sanctuary service that's reading
a lot of things in there. That's not
what Psalm 77 is talking about. But
notice too earlier you you used the
phrase our gospel
referring to Adventist. You said our
gospel and that's really the heart of it
is that the Adventist church has its own
gospel. That's what I was talking with
the previous gentleman about. It's a
unique present truth message that people
were not preaching before the Adventist
church was around. Well, Paul tells us
in Galatians 1, we've looked at it three
times tonight. I'm not going to bring it
back up, but Paul tells us in Galatians
1, if anyone comes preaching a different
gospel, that person's cursed. And that
what they received, the apostles, was
from Jesus Christ himself to then take
to other people. And he says, if anyone
comes preaching a different gospel than
what they were preaching as the gospel,
they're lost. So the gospel is not just
every bit of theology that I believe. It
is a specific message that is the power
of God to salvation. If what you just
described is the power of God into
salvation, the majority of Seventh Day
Adventists are not even saved because
the majority of them cannot even
articulate the investigative judgment.
They're completely confused. I talk with
these people constantly and I have my
whole life. The majority of them cannot
describe all of this stuff. Which means
the gospel must be one of the most
confusing messages in the world to
understand. When pe when when the
apostles were talking to the Philippian
jailer who said, "What must I do to be
saved?" They didn't say, "Well, sit down
here. I need you to give you about, you
know, a week's worth of of seminar and
break down for you all these different
seven steps and how this is this." And
they didn't go through any of that major
effort. The gospel is not that
complicated.
I
But then you Well, hold up, hold up,
hold up, hold up. You sorry. Like I
said, you you said a lot. And so I
wanted to be respectful of that, but I
got to respond to all this.
You you were mentioning Christ, but this
is also the problem. Tedla, definitions.
What do we mean by terms? Who's Christ?
You said we have to accept Christ into
our heart. Well, well, who is that?
Was Jesus was was Jesus exalted to be
made equal with the father? Is that is
that who Jesus is? He's a distinct being
from the father that prior to the
creation of the earth was exalted to be
made equal with the father such that
he's not co-eternally equal with the
father and the holy spirit because
that's what Ellen White said amongst a
number of other things. He was just a
man on earth. He set his divine nature
aside as we just showed in Monday's
video. Um that's what the Adventist
church's website says. They give the
standard kotic interpretation of
Philippians 2 that he was only a man on
earth because in the great controversy
he's our great example. So he had to be
just a man like we are while on earth to
show that we can do and walk in the same
footsteps that he did silencing the
accusations of Satan and the great
controversy etc. So who is Jesus? We
have to get into that as well. It's not
just a matter of saying the name because
Paul says in we looked at earlier, you
weren't here, but 2 Corinthians 11 1-4,
his concern for the Corinthian church
was that they were going to be led
astray after a different Jesus, which
would tell us just like Jesus says in
Matthew 24:24, there are false Jesuses
out there. There's false Christs out
there. So, the Adventist church doesn't
even have the correct Jesus.
Furthermore, all of this stuff is also
tied to the fact that in this system,
the Adventist church has Jesus up in
heaven wearing Levitical priesthood garb
doing work. analogous to the Levitical
ironic priesthood only in heaven. And
that the tearing of the temple veil
didn't signify the ability of man to now
be able to enter into the presence of
God because Jesus Christ's own flesh is
the curtain. Hebrews 10 we looked at
earlier and his flesh was torn on the
cross and he's the door. More imagery
about him being the door, which is
exactly what the curtain was. It was the
door symbolically for the the high
priest to be able to enter into the
presence of God. Well, that tore
separating that barrier, making a way
for us to now be able to enter with
boldness. 10 uh Hebrews 10:19-21.
And so, it didn't have to do with a
change or shift in the earthly temple is
now done away with, which it was
symbolic of now the heavenly temple
being inaugurated where Jesus is now
going to go up there and operate like a
Levitical ironic priest doing daily
ministry work until 1844 to then begin
the investigative judgment after that
where he's still dealing with sin. This
flies, this whole thing flies in the
face of the primary New Testament book
that we have regarding the sanctuary
services where the author the whole time
is doing a compare and contrast. He's
not laying out if if sal if the gospel
was like this, then the book of Hebrews
should look nothing like it does.
There's no mention of any of this stuff
of you're on the path just like Jesus
going through the seven steps and each
of these seven things represent, you
know, these spiritual applications and
etc.
Furthermore, you said you have to read
our Bibles. That was one of the the
things in there. The majority of
Christian history would be lost.
They'd be lost if the showbread is
supposed to show us the word of God such
that it's the bread of life that we need
to live on. Man does not live by I know
what Ellen states on this and how the
connection is made between man does not
live by bread alone, but by every word
that proceeds from the mouth of God. Um,
if that's the connection you see in the
showbread and this is the steps of
salvation,
did everyone up until the Adventist
position, were they on the same
sevenstep trajectory that the rest of us
are? Or is this only after 1844 when
this new light is present? Well, now all
of a sudden that's what that stuff
means. How did that apply this sanctuary
system to the majority of Christian
history? Just on that one step alone,
the bread being having to read the word
daily. I agree. You should be in the
word regularly. We're blessed to be able
to have such ease of access to it
digitally, physically, etc. And so I'm
I'm all for that. Um, but to make this a
part of what is ultimately your guys's
gospel message, uh, the majority of
Christians in in history be be lost. The
word of God was not readily accessible
like it is today throughout the majority
of Christian history. So they'd be
screwed. They had other ways of
catechizing and teaching, etc., to be
able to have access to it and whatnot.
Um the the concern again with kind of
all of this is that this is such a
convoluted message that it takes this
long to explain to someone what must
they do to be saved. And that's not the
gospel. I understand that in your guys'
system it it seems very consistent. I I
get it. I I trust me. I I'm I'm not just
a scoffer. I'm not just a bcker. I
understand the system. I understand it.
If I remember correctly, I'm pretty sure
you were someone that commented who
said, "You'd be shocked if if I was able
to describe the the seven steps of the
sanctuary, etc. It was a a couple months
back." Um, if you weren't, sorry about
that. But, um, no, I'm very aware of all
of this and I'm not doubting the fact
that you guys can present this and say,
"Look how consistent it is." The problem
becomes definitions of terms, which is
really what tonight is about. Who do we
mean when we say Jesus and what do we
mean by the gospel? So with all of that
said, you presented to us what you're
saying. Salvation is mired by the work
in the sanctuary. Paul tells us, I'm not
ashamed of the gospel. The power of God
is salvation for everyone who believes.
So what must I believe to be saved?
We're not talking about false faith
here. I'm talking about true belief. I
understand there's false faith out
there. There's people who make a
profession and it just it's obvious that
it's like you just were trying to check
the box to have fire insurance. You're
not the Holy Spirit hasn't actually
regenerated that person. We're not
talking about that situation. A person
who what Paul's saying here, he's not
ashamed of the gospel. It's the power of
God for salvation to everyone who
believes. I want salvation. What do I
have to believe? I have to believe this
sanctuary system that you just
presented.
Well, first of all, it's a personal
relationship. You don't know someone
overnight. So you can believe in Jesus
and now this spiritual growth takes
place. You have to learn about Jesus.
You have to walk with him and you'll get
to know him more and more and then tell
people about him more and more because
I'm sure when you started sharing the
gospel and you were just on fire telling
people what you knew at the time, but
then years later you knew more. And so
now you could tell people more about
Jesus. you experience
more about Jesus as well.
We got a halt there. We got a halt
there. We got a halt there. No, Tedler,
that that's the problem. That's the
problem.
See, we're we're crossing wires here.
And I'm going to get firm here, but I'm
not trying to be mean to you, but we
have to be honest about these things.
I'm concerned about Seventh Day
Adventist. And this is why Tedla, the
message I believed when I felt the power
of God into salvation is the same
message I'm preaching today. The exact
same message. Yes, my theological
learning has grown, but see, not all of
my theology is the gospel. This is the
problem. The gospel is a specific
message. This is why I keep going back
to Romans 1, the power of God to
salvation to everyone that believes it.
What is the it? What is the gospel?
We can't get that out of Adventists. And
that's the problem. That's why we're
concerned for you. You guys don't
understand the simple gospel. It's not
what you believe about eternal hell.
It's not what you believe about health.
It's not if you believe in synergism or
modernism or if you believe reformed or
Armenian. None of that stuff's the
gospel. Those are all different
theological facets. Every category of
theology is not the gospel. The gospel
is a specific message that when a person
hears it, it's what God uses. You quoted
this earlier, Romans 10:9. Faith comes
by hearing, hearing by the word of God.
How will they hear without a preacher?
Someone proclaims the message. A person
hears the message, the Holy Spirit uses
that because the Holy Spirit uses means
to then work upon a person causing a
change, regenerating the individual such
that they come to accept the good news,
which is the gospel. That's what the
gospel is. It's the good news. It's that
I'm a the bad news and the good news to
that bad news. That's why it's good news
is because well, there's bad news. The
bad news is is that we're sinners.
Yeah. We fall short. We've broken the
law of God.
Yes.
A a terrible predicament because the law
of God has no provisions for
forgiveness. It's do this and you'll
live. Do that and you'll die.
That's the righteous standard. Well, God
can't because he's just, he can't become
unjust or he wouldn't be who he is. He
he he ceases from being who he is in his
actual ontos in his being. So, he's
just. So, he has to punish sin because
we're sinners. But he's also merciful
and gracious and he he desires to
demonstrate that as well. He would be
right and just in condemning all of us
and saving no one. God is nobody
anything other than condemnation.
Yes. So, however, because God is rich in
mercy and he and his creatures, us are
in this predicament, God himself in the
person of Jesus Christ entered into his
own creation, doing what you and I have
failed to do.
He did so perfectly. Unlike the first
Adam, the second Adam perfect, kept the
covenant of works perfectly. He fulfills
those requirements, then goes to the
cross and pays the penalty undeserved of
himself,
paying the penalty for sin, overcoming
death, sin, the devil, and the grave.
Resurrects successfully,
demonstrating his sacrifice was
accepted, Romans 1:4. And now he rules
and reigns as his kingdom is
established. And he's taking essentially
by means of the church the gospel to all
the nations. And that good news is that
God himself has redeemed this creation.
It wasn't meant to be this way. He's
overcome all of this. And all of his
enemies are being made a foottool.
You're an enemy in his kingdom right
now. He's coming back one day, Luke 8,
to throw all of the lawb breakakers, the
wicked, out of his kingdom. So unless
you turn to him in faith and repentance
today and find that he is a perfect
savior, you will have a bad day coming.
And I don't want that for you. So turn
to Christ. Believe on the Lord Jesus
Christ, trusting in him perfectly in his
finished perfect work at Calvary in the
grave and in his perfect mediation in
heaven for his people. By doing so, God
will essentially change your heart. We
were talking about regeneration,
spiritual circumcision, etc. God
actually changes a person when they hear
and believe this message. That's the
good news. They're in Christ at that
point and they are pardoned. They're
justified. They have peace with God. We
went over this stuff earlier. Romans 4,
Romans 5, Roman Romans 5:1, Romans 8:1.
There's therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ. Well, how
do you get in Christ? By faith. Paul
explains you enter into Christ. By
faith. you are pardoned, spared from the
wrath to come. 1 Thessalonians 1:10 and
other places, even Romans 5, that Christ
was the propitiation. That's what that
word means. It has to do with wrath
being appeased. So the good news, the
gospel, the simple message is repent,
meaning turn from your sin to Jesus
Christ who is able to save to the
uttermost those who draw near to him.
And in doing so, he will remember none
of your sins anymore, which is a part of
the the new covenant promise, which is
quoted in in Jeremiah 31 as well as
Romans 8, which we looked at earlier. He
will engraft you into Christ, and you
will receive all of those benefits.
Right now, you're given a foreign alien
righteousness. Philippians 3:9. Well, 3
8-10 really. You're given an alien
foreign righteousness, not in small
little spurts over time. You're given
the full payment in full. Bam. when a
person truly believes. That's what
Protestantism was teaching about solid.
It was essentially saying there's a
dichotomy or a differentiation between
justification and sanctification. They
both happen. The argument wasn't well
there's no sanctification. The argument
was are the two things intertwined or
are they separate things? And the solid
position was saying it is a single thing
because it's a single declaratory act of
God that he declares when a person truly
believes. This person is completely
pardoned. All their sins I remember them
no more because they're hidden in Christ
Jesus. So when God looks at me, he
actually sees Christ. Does that mean
that each day I wake up and say, "Uh,
who cares? I just live however I want. I
I don't have any desire." No. No. that
that doesn't take into account the full
spectrum of the fact that God is the one
that changes you. Paul explains Romans 1
through3 that the naturally fallen
person is just hostile to God. They
don't have a desire for the things of
God. So part of it is yes, having a
desire. The issue is with the Adventist
church is that it's your continued
obedience that retains your
justification.
You're never going to get to a point
where you are keeping the law good
enough to earn God's favor. It's not
going to happen. It'll never happen. And
if you keep trusting in that, you're not
going to make it. That's not the gospel.
The gospel is the good news that I just
shared. It's that if you trust in the
true Christ and his gospel, you will
find that he is a perfect savior. He'll
cleanse your record completely of all of
your sins and you will have peace with
God right now. Not after some
investigative judgment. Not after it's
to be determined. And like Ellen said,
when you can breathe a sigh of relief
when you enter through the pearly gates
yourself. No. Right now, I have peace
with God. Just like Paul says, Romans
5:1, "Right this minute, I have peace
with God and nothing can condemn me. God
will keep me. I trust that Christ is a
perfect savior. I keep my eyes on him.
My hope is only in him." That's the
gospel. It's not having to understand
the sanctuary. It's not the health
message. It's not all these other things
that I know you haven't mentioned these
tonight, but I just bring these up again
because I have the the source
documentation from the Adventist Church.
This is what makes up the Adventist
gospel, which would mean the power of
God to salvation is understanding the
investigative judgment, leaving apostate
Protestant churches to join the remnant,
the seventh day Sabbath, health message,
Ellen White's writings, state of the
dead, uh, victory over sin, aka a
prepared people, and all these other
theological things that none of that's
the gospel. And that's the concern.
That's why we're concerned about you
guys is because it's really hard to
for Adventists to just explain the
gospel. I had a friend the other day.
I'm I'm like, man, let's just say this.
You had five minutes to tell some person
who's about to die. You feel convicted
in the moment to to share Christ with
this person. This person's an
unbeliever. What would you tell the
person? They're about to enter into
eternity. I know you guys don't believe
that if they're lost that it's forever,
but either way, we don't we want people
to come to know Christ if we claim to be
Christians. So, what would you tell a
person? The guy said, "Well, that's not
enough time."
That's the problem. That's the concern
is that the Adventist church doesn't
have the simple gospel. It's so craftily
formed to get people sidetracked on all
these other side things. It's not to say
that, well, the sanctuary can't teach us
things or, you know, maybe the Bible
does teach us things about health and
and lifestyle and it does teach us
things about Christian behavior. None of
that stuff is the gospel, though. Not
all of theology is the gospel. So,
that's that's the concern.
Well, okay, you mentioned a whole bunch
of stuff, but anyhow.
Yeah.
Justification
takes place first, right?
Yep.
Then
what is just what's what's
justification?
Well, you have to accept Jesus Christ.
And you have to say, I surrender all. I
surrender my desires, my sinful desires.
I I'm a sinner in need of grace. And
Christ will come into your heart and and
and he will empower you to live a holy
life. But it's not once saved, always
saved. That's the thing that we have to
understand.
I don't affirm once saved, always saved.
That's a 19th century novel.
Yes, some people do.
Well, no, no. I I I know. But
that's one of those things that the
Adventist Church oftentimes caricatures
any person that believes in
perseverance. They automatically believe
once saved, always saved. And again,
once saved, always saved is a 19th
century novelty. That's not the historic
understanding of perseverance. So, I'm
not I'm not affirming that and and
espousing that.
But but that's not what justification
is, though. Before we can move forward,
that's not what justification is. So,
let's go to the scriptures. Okay.
Well, we're all sinners. We're all
sinners and because we transgress the
law.
Yeah. Well, let's let's let the
scriptures teach us. Okay. Go ahead.
Okay.
So, we're going to read a number of
things here and we're going to close off
on this because we're approaching the
three-hour mark. Folks, those of you
that have been here from the beginning,
God bless you. Thank you for being here.
If you like content like this, make sure
to check out answering adventism.com. We
have all sorts of resources over there
and stuff is growing daily. But let's
look quickly here. Romans 4 into the
beginning of chapter 5. I'm going to
read it all and we're going to see what
what Paul is laying out here because
Paul is explaining as you're seeing. I
know the headings are not inspired, but
they do inform what we're about to read.
Abraham justified by faith. This is
after Paul in chapter 3 has explained to
us how regardless of being a Jew or a
Gentile, all people are in the same
boat. They're sinful. They're fallen.
They have no hope. That's the the
conclusion. So then he transitions into
well actually toward the end of there he
actually does say about um some stuff
about justification and how um we're not
justified essentially by law and um but
here he gives us an example of
justification. Okay. So he says what
then shall we say uh was gained by
Abraham our forefather according to the
flesh. So do you know what this phrase
according to the flesh means?
So say that again sins according to the
flesh. Yeah. Yeah. Do you know what the
phrase according to the flesh means?
Scripture uses this very regularly. It's
predominantly used of of Christ. So, for
example, in Romans 1:3, um it says it
talks about Jesus and says according to
the flesh, as well as Romans 9:5, it
says according to the flesh. And it's
referring to uh Christ. Do you know what
it's referring to when it says that?
It's referring to their the human the
human nature. So when they do it with
Christ, that's a a way in scripture that
they differentiate between his human and
divine natures. So when it's talking
about his divine nature, they'll say in
his spirit. So in the gospels, for
example, when the Pharisees were coming
up against him in well in Matthew and
Luke at least, it says in his spirit, he
perceived what they were thinking in
their hearts. That's the author saying
in his divine nature, he was able to
see. Because first Kings 8:39 says only
God can see the hearts of men. only
Yahweh is able to do that. Well, then
Jesus does that. And so, it's referring
to his divine nature. But then when it
says according to the flesh, it's
referring to the human nature. So, here
is that that's exactly what he's saying.
What then shall we say was gained by
Abraham our forefather according to the
flesh, according to his doings. You
could say, for if Abraham was justified
by works, he has something to boast
about, but not before God.
Sanctification includes works. Correct.
Sanctification, faith, and works.
Yeah. Yeah. Sanctification is where
works come into play. Right.
Right. So if Abraham was justified by
works, that would include
sanctification. He has something to
boast about, but not before God. For
what does the scripture say? Then he
quotes Genesis 15 here. Abraham believed
God and it was counted to him as
righteousness.
That's before he circumcised. That's
before he took obeyed and took Isaac up
the mountain. Abraham believed God. And
that was credited to him as
righteousness.
Now the one who works his wages are
counted as a gift or are not counted as
a gift but as his due. So you're work if
you're working and doing something you
receive wages for the the work that you
do. But in contrast to this that's not
how the gospel is. There's no sort of
work that's done where then you receive
the wages for what you've done.
Salvation is not like that. Again,
staying in line with this, Abraham
believed and it was credited to him as
righteousness. Not a fake belief. I'm
not saying easy belieism, but he simply
believed and it was at that moment, bam,
it was credited him as righteousness.
And to the one who does not work,
but believes in him who justifies the
ungodly, his faith is counted as
righteousness. So, we get people who
will say, "Well, right, right, right,
but you can't separate the two." Yes,
you can. Yes, you can separate the two
because the two are not the same.
Justification is a one-time declaration
from God on behalf of a person. They're
justified from there. They're then moved
to the next step and it will happen
successfully because God doesn't fail.
When God regenerates a person, God is a
a a savior. He's able to save people. He
doesn't just open the door and make
things a possibility. He actually
declares the person righteous. And at
that point they're moved from
justification to a new category of
sanctification.
But in that category sanctification's
not maintaining the justification.
The justification's already happened.
Bam. Declared righteous.
And to the one who does not work but
believes in him him who justifies the
ungodly, his faith is counted as
righteousness. Just as David also. So
now again he appeals to the Old
Testament to show this same thing. Just
as David also speaks of the blessing of
the one whom God counts righteousness
apart from works.
If if righteousness came by both works
or sanctification and justification, you
wouldn't be able to say what he's he's
saying here. Blessed are those whose
lawless deeds are forgiven and whose
sins are covered. Blessed is the man
against whom the Lord will not count his
sin. This is in inconsistency with um
Jeremiah 31 and the talk about the new
covenant. The fact that our sins are not
remembered anymore, which is another
problem for the sanctuary model is that
our sins are still remembered because
they're still being dealt with in a
sanctuary up in heaven. But
nevertheless, in this blessing then only
for or is this blessing then only for
the circumcised or also the
uncircumcised? He's talking to Jews here
who would have understood this to be is
it only for Jews or or um also for
Gentiles? For we say that faith was
counted to Abraham as righteousness. How
then was it counted to him? Was it
before or after he'd been circumcised?
So this is where we're now getting into
sanctification. His outworking now
walking out his faith.
How then was it counted to him? Was it
before or after? It was not after but
before he was circumcised.
He received the sign of circumcision as
a seal of the righteousness that he had
by faith while he was still
uncircumcised. There is so much that I
could say here on this specific verse,
the connection with baptism, just so
many things. So many things. But the
point is is that the circumcision that
he received was a sign of a present
reality.
It was a sign of the righteousness that
he had by faith while he was still
uncircumcised. But circumcision was a
part of the sanctification. It's a part
of the works. It's a part of the
obedience. Yet Paul says before that
even happened, he was already declared
righteous.
The purpose was to make him the father
of all who believe without being
circumcised so that righteousness would
be counted to them as well. That's us.
And to make him the father of the
circumcised, who are not merely
circumcised, but who also walk in the
footsteps of the faith that our father
Abraham had before he was circumcised.
For the promise to Abraham and his
offspring that he would be heir of the
world did not come through the law but
through the righteousness of faith. For
it is the adherence of the law who are
to be or for it is the adherence of the
law who are to be heirs. Faith is sorry.
For if it is the adherence of the law
who are to be heirs, faith is null and
the promise is void. For the law brings
wrath, but where there is no law, there
is no transgression. That is why it
depends on faith. in order that the
promise may rest on grace and be
guaranteed to all his offspring. Again,
guaranteed.
It has nothing to do with a wage,
something that somebody gets in return
for something that they've done. We
looked at Ellen White Ellen White quotes
earlier where she talks about um
salvation essentially being a reward
that one receives based on the choices
that they make in terms of their
continual working of the the law. But
that's not what he's saying here. And he
says, ' Not only to the adherent of the
law, but also the one who shares the
faith of Abraham, who's the father of us
all. As it is written, I've made you the
father of many nations. Again, quoting
Genesis, in the presence of the God in
whom he believed, who gives life to the
dead and calls into existence in
existence things that do not exist. In
hope, he believed against hope that he
should become the father of many
nations. As he had been told, so shall
your offspring be. He did not weaken in
faith when he considered his own body,
which was as good as dead since he was
about a hundred years old or when he
considered the barrenness of Sarah's
womb. No unbelief made him waver
concerning the promise of God. But he
grew strong in his faith as he gave
glory to God. He's laying out here that
Abraham had a true living faith. He
wasn't just paying lip service, you
know, it wasn't like, oh, I just don't
want to go to the bad place, so I just
want to get my ticket punched. No, he
actually believed God, trusted God, but
still the focus is on his faith. It was
faith that did this. No unbelief, which
is the opposite of faith, made him waver
concerning the promise of God. But he
grew strong in his faith as he gave
glory to God, fully convinced that God
was able to do what he had promised.
This is why his faith was counted to him
as righteousness. Again, it is a true
faith, a living faith. So yes, there
will be works that follow, but the focus
is still on faith. Just like in James
chapter 2, James is comparing and
contrasting two types of faith, living
faith and dead faith. And people will
point there and say, "See, well, he says
the living faith has works." Yes, of
course. But the whole thing in focus is
two types of faith. It's faith that's
the focus. And it's faith that brought
about Abraham's righteousness. But the
words, "It was counted to him were not
written for his sake alone, but for ours
also. It will be counted to us who
believe in him who raised from the dead,
Jesus our Lord, who was delivered up for
our trespasses and raised for our
justification." Then the very next verse
that he says, it's a therefore. So after
all that, therefore, since we have been
have been justified by faith, we have
peace with God through our Lord Jesus
Christ.
What does he end it with?
But the words, "It was counted to him,
were not written for his sake alone, but
for ours also. It will be counted to us
who believe in him who raised from the
dead, Jesus our Lord, who was delivered
up for our trespasses and raised for our
justification. That's the gospel,
the perfect work of the God man, Jesus
Christ. Any person who places their
faith in him, meaning they turn from
their sins to trusting in Jesus Christ,
Jesus, I believe who you say you are. I
trust that you did what you did. I trust
that you were raised on the third day,
that you paid the penalty for my sins. I
want to uh know you. You know, word it
however you want there. The point is is
turning to Christ by faith and trusting
in the person and work of Christ. That's
how a person's justified. Justification
is being counted righteous. That's what
justification is. And that's a one-time
thing. It's not something that happens
with a contingency like an asterk and
then read the fine print and well if you
continue you know in this and and you do
this and this and I'm not poo pooing
good works don't don't hear me saying
you know that doesn't mean you you you
don't but the good works will naturally
come from being justified because the
ungodly person Paul has already
described in Romans 1 through3 they
don't have those desires they don't want
to seek for God they're not seeking for
God this act of grace that he bestows on
us is something he freely does and it
produces a change in us of course but
when I do good works I'm never thinking
these are maintaining my justification
or you know you get into pyotism like oh
well did I read my Bible enough today oh
am I still saved or I I you should not
think that way that's not how people in
Christ should think it should naturally
just flow out these sorts of things and
yeah when you fall you should be in in
prayer you should be in communion with
God you should be confessing those
things not because oh if I don't I lost
my salvation or God does not operate
that way. That's not the good news of
the gospel. The good news of the gospel
is yeah obviously God does not leave us
the way that we are and you will walk
out in works of of of righteousness
absolutely through the power of the Holy
Spirit. No doubt there. The problem is
is and we looked at the quote earlier
that the Adventist church is teaching
how you're reconciled to God is by faith
and works. And Paul just said here that
if that were the case, it wouldn't have
been able to been said by David, about
Abraham, etc. Reconciliation does not
come from faith and obedience. It only
comes by faith in the true and living
God.
I hear what you're saying. I that's such
a deep topic. Sanctification, I believe,
is something that we because I hear a
lot of people say, "Okay, we get through
justification, but sanctification has to
be the next step." you're growing. And
in the Bible, you know, Saul, I'm not
talking about Paul, but King Saul.
Yeah.
It says that God changed his heart in
his earlier when he was first starting
off
and then he fell. So, you have to
basically maintain your relationship.
God shows you how to walk,
right? And then the more we know how to
walk, we stay off of the fact that we we
can because we can fall and we can stay
down. We you know sometimes we we get
twisted and we we fall into the worldly
desires. So we have to maintain our
relationship and learn more and and
that's beholding Christ. I was going to
throw a wrench in there because I know
you had a list of things and no one I
guess attempted to answer any of those.
I know you have to go. I'm just going to
leave a a thought.
Um because we we all have
Can I say can I say one thing real real
quick just about what you were saying
earlier? Um but the the question becomes
see the the the argument is not
sanctification doesn't happen. I agree
it definitely happens because I believe
God's the author and finisher of the
whole the whole thing and God doesn't
fail
at what he started. He's perfect savior.
He's able to he's able to actually save
people. And so the argument is not
around whether or not you believe in
justification and sanctification or just
justification. The issue would become
what you just described is essentially
saying you maintain your justification
after it happens through sanctification.
But see that's exactly what the the
reformation that's that's like one of
the heart issues of the reformation of
why the reformation happened.
That's why the law gospel the the law
gospel distinction is well and I get
that. But you you guys are on the the
Arasmian side. You guys are on the Roman
Catholic side.
Whether you guys know that or not, that
that's what you're you're saying there.
Because what you're saying is that a
person is is of course justified by
grace through faith. It's only by God.
If God didn't open up the doorway and
make it possible, obviously we'd all be
lost. There's no way. But he does that.
And then when you place your faith in
him, sure you're justified. But then you
have in Adventist theology, they don't
use the term final justification. They
use esqueatological justification.
That's the term that your scholars use.
So there's two tiers of justification.
It's not a single time thing at one
point that then will automatically lead
to sanctification. And that
sanctification will be finished a
finished product because God will finish
that work that he's doing in the person
that he started. It's that you're
initially justified and then your
continued obedience maintains that
justification. No, sanctification does
not maintain your justification. You're
working for your salvation.
Well, you got to live by the word. Um
I I agree. But that doesn't have to do
with reconciling you. That doesn't have
to do with reconciling you, though. If
you're looking to those things, though,
as this is maintaining your
justification, this is keeping me right
with God, you're you're not looking to
Christ. That's not looking to Christ.
When I look at and behold Christ, Christ
makes me more like him.
Yeah.
And in the process of doing that, I'm
not re I'm not maintaining my
justification.
That's just the natural now outflowing
of having already been justified. I have
peace with God. That's changed my life.
I live my life in a different way. In
this model that you guys are presenting,
there's all sorts of hiccups that could
completely throw you off the wagon. And
all of it is dependent upon you. It's
not salvation by grace alone through
faith alone in Christ alone, which is
the heart of the the reformation. That
that's not what you guys are are that's
not what your guys' message is saying.
The focus like the the the earlier guy
that was on here, he's a really nice
guy, but everything he was saying and
kind of what you've been saying as well
is you're looking to yourself. I
understand you're saying, "No, no, it's
all about Jesus." But really, when when
it boils down to it, you're saying Jesus
has done his part. He's done everything
that he can possibly do. Now the ball is
in your court.
No, that's not
and you
Well, well, that's the practical
outworking of it is that Jesus has
opened the door making the way of
salvation a possibility. You can take
hold by uh your faith in the merits of
Christ and be empowered through the
power of the Holy Spirit to now start
cooperating alongside Jesus to
eventually get to a point where you will
be reconciled. Because in your guys'
system, reconciliation is not complete
yet because you've lumped in the
restoration of all things. you kind of
mentioned that with the sin being
removed from the camp analogy, etc. Um,
you don't really have reconciliation yet
because Jesus is still dealing with your
sin. So, that is what's being said. It's
your salvation really is dependent upon
you and what you're doing and your own
behavior. And if that's really the case
and you're being honest daily, you you
know that you don't measure up to the
standard. So, you're you're never going
to get to a place where, you know, why
is it that if if it's that the Holy
Spirit is has you on this path where
you're eventually going to get to a
sinlessly perfect state, which is the
ultimate goal, um then why haven't you
arrived yet? Well, again, it goes back
to yourself. Well, because you know, God
is again, he's trying his best, but it
still is just not enough because he's
not able to overcome the the things that
you're doing. Whereas, I would argue the
picture painted by the Bible is that God
changes us. When you're a new creature
in Christ, you're changed and you have
new desires. And Paul explains in Romans
7, the war that starts to take place
between the old man and the new man
after being regenerate. That war is
going to happen your whole life. You,
you know, I try diligently, trust me, I
I'm a I'm a very uh I don't remember
what the term is, but I have a very like
easily guilted conscience where I tend
to kind of overthink things. There's
some psychological reasons why that's
the case, but nevertheless, um I tend to
really focus in on those things. And so
again, I'm not advocating like, oh, you
just live however you want. But if
you're looking to your own behavior to
measure up to the markers of if you're
on the pathway and if you're going to
make it, that's not the gospel. That is
that is not the gospel.
You have to basically yield yourself.
Like God doesn't take away your freedom
of choice,
right? But to be reconciled to be
reconciled though see I'm not arguing
for I'm not arguing we I agree we we
make choices we have a will now whether
that will is is influenced by things and
whether you're a slave to sin etc is
another discussion but I I agree with
that Teddler that the issue is how are
you reconciled what we just looked at
with what Paul says and we could go to
other places
is that a person's reconciled he goes
into chapter five actually the very next
verses and we looked at these earlier
you weren't here but we looked at them
with Another guy, Ellen Ellen White says
in her quote, "Man is is who has defaced
the image of God." Here it is. In his
soul, by corrupt life cannot by mere
human effort affect a radical change in
himself. This is what you were saying
earlier. Of course, it can't, you know,
you can't do it of yourself. He must
accept the provisions of the gospel. He
must be reconciled to God through
obedience to his law and faith in Jesus
Christ. No. No. Paul literally just
refuted that in in Romans chapter 4. He
says the exact opposite. It was only the
faith that did that did that. And then
he continues into chapter 5 to tell us
what it's faith in after he tells us
there at the tail end that he didn't
just you know but these words that was
counted to him were not written only for
his sake alone but for ours also. It
will be counted to us who believe in him
who raised from the dead Jesus our Lord
who was delivered up for our trespasses
and raised for our justification.
Therefore we have peace with God. And
then he goes on to explain how we are
reconciled and it's by faith in the
person and work of Jesus not by any
works. Works are something that happen
in sanctification. And also this is
where the law gospel distinction comes
into play which was another core
foundational thing to the Protestant
Reformation. Law and gospel are not the
same thing.
You see when it comes to like Cain and
Abel
brought that's not that's not a
sotiological
No. No. But what I'm trying to say is
Abel brought what God requested.
Cain didn't. Cain wanted to do it his
own way. And I think that's where the
works come in in context. We can't do it
by our own works, our own way. Christ is
the way. He shows us the way. And we
have to follow him through the spirit.
The spirit guides us to through through
truth. So that's where our mind has to
be. It's like God, how do you want me to
live? That's the way I want to walk. You
know, you got to do it the way he said.
I hear you. I I hear you. And I think
you're missing what I'm saying, though,
we're talking about reconciliation. So,
do you think that by yielding to to
that, like you just said,
I'm not disagreeing with you. A person
has to yield to the spirit of God
because in this whole chain, the spirit
now indwells a person. They're a new
creature in Christ, which there's a lot
attached to that phrase. It's more than
just behavior modification. We've gotten
on the into this on the channel before.
I'm not going to get into it now, but of
course, because in this whole chain,
you're taken from being a you're dead.
We're dead in our trespasses and sins.
That's not just metaphorical whatever
language. And I understand the Adventist
Church has a different view of the
nature of man. So, their understanding
on this has to be somewhat changed. It
has to be metaphorical. But no, we're
there's a aspect of us that is dead,
fallen, in sin. And God raises those
dead bones to life.
So when he does that, he quickens a
person. That's regeneration. The lights
go on, so to speak. The spirit now
indwells a person. It's at that point
they're credited righteous. It's there's
a whole host of things here. So I'm not
disagreeing with anything regarding we
have to, of course, of course, but not
to be reconciled. Not to be reconciled.
And that's the the thing that we kind of
keep getting away from tonight. That is
the main thing that's the issue that's
in view. He must be reconciled to God
through obedience to his law and faith
in Jesus. No. No. You're reconciled to
God by faith because, and we talked
about this earlier, you weren't here,
but you enter into Christ, which is a
term of of union with Christ. It's it's
a salvific term, being in him, in
Christ, etc. Paul uses that in Romans
8:1. Therefore, there is no therefore
now no condemnation for those in Christ
Jesus. There are all sorts of things
that come with being in Christ.
adoption, forgiveness of sins,
transferred from the kingdom of darkness
into the kingdom of light. All of these
things are the benefits of Christ that a
person receives at the moment of being
in him. We enter into him by faith and
we're reconciled to God through the
person of Jesus Christ. Not any of our
own doings. All of this that stuff is in
a separate category. It's in a different
category. And if I sound like I'm
getting a little worked up, I'm not, you
know, I'm not mad or anything. I'm just
I'm passionate here because I care. I
care about you guys. Seriously, this is
a serious thing. You you you really got
to hear what's being said here because
I'm telling you what the Adventist
church is putting forth. That's not
that's not the gospel because they're
intermixing law with gospel, which is
what the reformation was trying to uh uh
essentially
with the scholastics coming in and just
a number of things there. certain things
got clouded and they wanted to
rightfully bring the the faithful
proclamation of the word of God back to
the the the place it it needed within
within the church alongside the the
Eucharist. But nevertheless,
Go ahead. Sorry.
I was just going to say that the concern
is specifically how are you reconciled?
And what you're describing and what the
Adventist Church is also putting forth
and what that Ellen White quote is
putting forth is you're not reconciled
by Christ alone. by faith alone in
Christ alone. You're reconciled by
faith. Of course, it has to be by, you
know, by faith and faith in the merits
of Christ.
But then after that, your doings retain
that justification and will determine if
you are ultimately finally justified.
That is a two-tiered system of
justification. And that's that's that's
not what Paul was was teaching.
And that's the concern for SDAs. That's
that's part of why the gospel is false.
Now, the things I had up on screen
earlier, the the list of things, I was
bringing those up at the tail end of my
discussion because when I re was reading
these Ellen White quotes, I was
specifically focusing on the false
understanding of reconciliation
and that that aspect of Adventist
theology, which is a ser I mean,
reconciliation encompasses
justification, how you're made right
with God. That's what reconciliation is.
So, I was focusing on that there. But I
brought these up to specifically talk
about on top of the change of of
reconciliation, the definition of that.
The Adventist Church's gospel, the three
angels message entails all of these
excess doctrines that have nothing to do
with the gospel.
You don't have to believe the
investigative judgment to be saved.
That's not the power of God to
salvation. Neither is leaving apostate
Protestantism and joining the Adventist
church or going to church on Saturday or
the health message or Ellen White's
writings, etc. None of those things are
the gospel. They're theological
categories and they're things that there
are theological topics, you know, that
you can study and whatnot, but those are
not the power of God to salvation.
That's not what the apostles preached.
That's not what the early church
believed. That's not what you you can't
find investigative judgment anywhere
before 1844.
I just want to say like John 15 verse
5-6 says it talks about to abide to
abide in Christ.
Yeah, we talked about this earlier.
Yeah,
to remain in his will, right? So
yeah,
you want to abide and remain. That means
you can fall that you can fall like a
branch. So I know we have a little bit
of time but going back to those things
the penalty of the law is is death. Not
only that but it's eternal separation
from from God. Right now Christ when he
died he was he he he paid for for the
penalty you know um but in terms of
being eternal separation eternally
separated from God that has to fall on
someone. And that goes back to um the
scapegoat.
Satan will be eternally separated and
those who choose to follow him will be
eternally separated from God.
That's that's
I don't want it's a can of worms, but I
just wanted to mention one of the items
you had on the list because no one
touched it. So, I just wanted to to
mention that, but we don't have to go.
We just had we just had a discussion on
that from last week. I don't know if you
saw that or not. um where we we kind of
went deep on that. So I'll point people
to that if they want to see my my
responses there. But Teda again John 15
this is and the guy that was on here
earlier he he mentioned this as well and
I want to steer away from the idea
because oftentimes Adventists think well
see it's you're saying that the the the
gospel is once saved always saved and so
it's like well if I can show somewhere
where that's but but see people that
don't necessarily believe once saved
always saved Teddla believe the same
gospel that I do. They may disagree
about mechanics, but we're not dis I'm
not disagreeing about the mechanics with
the Adventist church. I'm saying
outright they've added things to the
gospel. I don't believe only reformed
people are saved. For example, I'm
reformed. That's not what the reformers
taught or believed. They didn't say
everyone outside of us is lost. You have
to be No. So, this isn't even something
that's just unique to me. This is what
Christians universally believe. This is
the thing that one of the things out of
two that ties all Christians together.
Who is God? What is the gospel? That's
the foundation of the of Christianity.
Not esquetology, not end times, not the
scapegoat, not the judgment, none of
that stuff.
You mentioned something there and just
you mentioned about health, right? The
Bible says that our body is the temple
of God. If you don't maintain healthy,
yeah, you if you don't maintain good
health, that could mess with your mind.
And remember, Satan is after your mind.
God is after your mind. So
right,
health is very important. That's
something where you can't say, you know,
I don't need to worry about health. I
just need to worry about the gospel.
That's totally contradict.
I'm not saying that. I'm not saying that
you don't need to worry about anything
else outside of this. I'm not saying
that at all. I'm I think Eucharistic
theology is very important. For example,
um but I don't think that people
disagree with me on the Eucharist are
are lost or have a different gospel. Uh
these are all different areas of
theology, but they're not the gospel and
they're not the thing that reconciles a
person. You know, the health message has
nothing to do with being justified and
made right with God. That's the point.
It's not saying that the Bible has
nothing to say about health. It's not
saying the Bible has nothing to say
about judgment. It's not saying the
Bible has nothing to say about um you
know, whether or not we are
immortal or conditionally immortal, etc.
It's just those things are not the
gospel. That's the concern. And it's
it's very hard for Adventists to
understand the simple gospel. Christians
are united in their love for the one
true God and the gospel. That's what
unites them. We have all sorts of other
disagreements. We have great in-house
discussions. I don't do it on this
platform, but I'm very active in all
sorts of other theological discussions
outside of this platform on a variety of
topics. The difference is is we're
having in-house discussions. If a person
has a false god and a false gospel,
that's not an in-house discussion. We
can't talk about the law of God when the
God that you're proitizing is a false
god. Who cares about what do you mean
the law of God? What god? You can't even
talk about these other things unless
you're on that same foundation. So,
that's the concern. That's the worry.
Um, and we talked about, like I
mentioned, we talked about John 15 and
Romans 11 earlier about abiding. And
there's really a deeper conversation
there about covenant. Paul uses that
same imagery of the tree to talk about
covenant. There are those who are um
visibly in the covenant. There's there
are those who are visibly as well as
invisibly in the covenant. Meaning there
are people in your local church who you
believe are Christians because they're
there. They're at Bible study. That you
know, you're seeing the fruit and you
say, "Yeah, I think this person's a
Christian." But at the end of the day,
you don't know because you can't see any
you can't see anybody's heart. That's
the invisible aspect. So those who are
united to Jesus Christ by faith, I can't
see who that actually is and who that
who their heart is. But the people who
are visibly there, who are not invisibly
attached, they're still on the tree.
They just haven't been cut off yet.
They're not attached to the root.
So they're going to be trimmed off
eventually because they're never truly
in Christ. So you can visibly be a part
of the the church, but not actually be
united to Christ by faith. And that's
what's going on there. the the branches
that don't abide in him, those are the
people who are then cut off. I would
make the argument, which we're not going
to get into all this tonight because
again, we've gone for three and a half
hours now, so we do need to cut things
short um or cut things cut things loose
here. We'll be here all night. Um it's
it's a discussion about covenant but
really the core of all this Ted was to
say that none of that stuff has to do
with reconciliation and that was kind of
the thing that was in focus there on top
of the fact that the Adventist church
has added all sorts of doctrines to the
gospel message and none of these things
are the gospel message and Paul says
anybody that does such a thing is cursed
by God.
You mentioned reconciliation.
You're reconciled. What's your next
step? You know what I mean? like there
has to be a next step after you
surrendered your life to God and now you
have to walk by faith and and and have a
holy living. That's something after.
I I know and and that's why I've I've
said this I don't know how many times
now.
Um
I agree with you. More things will
follow. It's not saying this is the end.
That's not what I'm saying. But at step
one, the Adventist church is off. The
Adventist church is off on step one. So
we can't even move to discussing the
second step when we haven't established
that the first step is correct. That's
that. So that's why we're we're camping
out on this. That's the first initial
problem is that you're you're trying to
take step two and make it a part of step
one such that they're a single step. See
what I'm saying? It's that your
justification is maintained over the
course of time based on your behavior.
No, it's not. Because if that were the
case, Teddla, you're not loving God
perfectly with every thought, word,
deed, and motive. That's the standard.
Not trying, but actually successfully
doing it. That's what Jesus did. He
loved God perfectly with every thought,
word, motive, deed, etc. every second,
247. That's the standard. We fall short
of that standard. And so unless Christ
is able to give you his his foreign
alien righteousness, that's the only way
that you can actually meet the standard.
not over time by your continued perfect,
you know, aiming for perfect obedience
through the help of the Holy Spirit.
That's not going to get you there. And
then Christ will just supplement in
where you fall short. No, that that's
not going to do it for you. It's only by
faith alone in Christ alone that you are
then reconciled. God will change you,
make you a new creature in Christ. And
yes, your your life will be marked by a
a change. But if you could lose your
salvation like that, Tedla, the way that
you're describing it, you would. you'd
be out immediately because you're not
loving God perfectly with every thought,
word, deed, and motive. It's not just
the letter of the Ten Commandments. And
even that, we're not doing. And I would
argue that you're you're violating the
first commandment. If you believe the
the great controversy narrative and the
fact that Jesus was supposedly exalted
to be made equal with the father, etc.,
that's a false god. That's an idol. So,
right there, if you don't know the true
Christ, you're already violating the ten
the ten commandments in the letter. Let
alone if you're putting anything else in
your life ahead of God, which I would
argue all of us do daily, whether you're
consciously aware of it or not. The
whole point is that the standard is so
high that only in Christ can you be seen
as righteous. And you need to trust in
Christ alone, not your daily getting up
and doing this and that, which I again,
I get up, I seek to lead my family as
God calls me to. I spend time in the
word. I'm catechizing my son. I disciple
my wife. I'm accountable to the local
church. You know, I have all these, but
none of these things are maintaining my
justification. None of it. All of those
things.
Well, and I agree. But again, it doesn't
maintain justification. That's the key.
It does not maintain justification,
which the Adventist church is teaching.
It maintains your justification. And
your ultimate final justification will
be determined based on what you do,
which the Bible has no category for two
tiers of justification. So that's the
primary issue. come back. Um, we're
going to be doing this again. I know
that um, you probably had more that you
wanted to say, but again, we could end
up being here all night. I've already
gone uh, about an hour over what I
anticipated doing, but this was really
good. I'm glad that some SDAs decided to
show up and people could see that I'm
not as mean of a person as people often
think. Um, and I do like having these
discussions with people. You have been
um, enjoyable to talk to. So, thank you
for coming on. I've seen your comments
and stuff before, so it's nice to be
able to chat with you, as well as the
other two guests that previously came
on. Um, so I will let you go if you have
any final things that you just want to
share real quick before I um let you go
and do our sign off for the night.
Yeah, I just want to say one thing. I do
appreciate the fact that you're looking
deep into I guess everything we teach
because the average 7day Adventist
doesn't right and so
there's many different minds as what we
really teach even from a higher level of
leadership. Um so a lot of people don't
really read what we really teach. Um, so
I do appreciate that. I I know that
context is key and and we we would have
to
it's it's a sit down for certain things,
man. It doesn't happen just in one shot.
That's why this conversation sometimes
it could not get to a place it needs to
go. But yeah, that's all I I got to say.
Well, thank you. Thanks for the kind
words. And like I said, I um I try and
study these things from from again
primary source material. I don't like to
do the old uh well Joe Schmo over here
said this and so that's you know um
again we on this platform we try and
deal with primary source materials.
Primary sources being official organs of
the SDA church uh Adventist Review
scholars people like George Knight Ellen
White the pioneers etc because I'm not
sure of any higher sources of of you
know source materials to be referencing.
So I appreciate that. Um, come back next
time when we do this. Like I said, we
will uh
be doing these. I don't I don't know how
frequently. Um, but I would like to do
stuff like this more often. My mind was
not changed tonight, folks. Um, not that
I I thought it would be. I I mainly
wanted to just have some conversations
with SDAs and let other people see these
these sorts of dialogues and these sorts
of back and forths and the problems that
um this platform and many others that I
know have with the Adventist church and
the discussions tonight kind of
encompass that folks. Um it has to be
has to be stressed.
The gospel is not every tidbit of
theology that we believe. That's not the
gospel. That's not the power of God into
salvation.
There's all sorts of things that I
believe that people disagree with me on.
That's fine. They're not under a curse
from God because they're not preaching a
different gospel because they disagree
on this facet over here. And the concern
we have for Adventists, we didn't get
into the Adventist Jesus really at at
all tonight as much as I would have
liked to because that's another key
component of all this is that the gospel
is Jesus's gospel. And if you have the
wrong Jesus, then you can't possibly
have the right gospel. And so, um, that
that's the concern, Adventists, is we're
using a lot of the same language. We
don't mean the same things. Um, and we
have to we have to start defining these
things. And the gospel is not this
convoluted sort of thing that takes all
this, you know, 25 minutes to explain to
somebody. It's not again to say that
there aren't aspects of it that are
meteor and richer, etc. But folks, the
gospel message is a simple message. It's
just like the thief on the cross. Like,
it's not to say that people don't grow.
If if the thief wouldn't have died, he
probably would have, if he was truly
saved, would have gone on and walked out
in his life. And obviously, God would
have grown him. But it's that same
gospel message that saved him. Not some
different thing that he learns over time
where it's like, "Oh man, I got more
light. Now I realize the gospel is
actually this." And then you keep
studying and oh no, the gospel is that.
No, no, the gospel is transcendent. The
gospel was present in the Old Testament
book of Hebrews. We hear about that. You
fail to enter the rest. If you fail to
believe the gospel, that's how you enter
into the true rest, which is a whole
another can of worms. For folks that are
curious about that, you can go to
answerism.com. Just type in Hebrews 4 in
the uh the search bar and you can see my
exegetical presentation of Hebrews 1
through 11 um for more on that. But
hopefully this was beneficial to you
tonight, folks. Um I had a good time
talking with you guys. Like I said,
we'll do this again. and hopefully some
more SDAs or some of the same SDAs can
show up and we can continue to flesh out
these these very specifics. But we're
going to keep hammering on this
platform, folks. Um, you have to come to
know that the the true gospel, the
simple basic gospel. It has nothing to
do with any of this stuff. It has
nothing to do with any of these
doctrines. These may be theological
doctrines you hold to, you believe. Um,
I would argue that say the investigative
judgment, for example, is compromising
the gospel. So simply holding on to it
is not um going to be consistently
possible with the true gospel. But
nevertheless, the power of God to
salvation is none of these things. The
power of God to salvation is the same
gospel message that's been here from the
beginning, which was preached long
before even the incarnation. Paul, as we
saw, appeals to uh Abraham to talk about
the same, you know, message of how a
person's reconciled and made right with
God, which is really the good news. The
good news is that you can be reconciled
to God. You can have peace with God
today. Therefore, there's no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus. Of course, your life is going to
be marked by a change because when
you're born again, you're a new
creature. Of course, there's going to be
fruit that now starts to produce, but
the fruit is not the root. And the fruit
does not continually sustain the root.
It's the other way around. The root
sustains the fruit production. That's
the key. That's the key. And the simple
gospel message is that any person that
turns to Christ in faith and repentance
will find that he is a perfect savior.
He will change you. He will forgive you
of all of your sins, remember them no
more. You'll have peace with God. That's
the message. Do you believe that Jesus
is who he says he is? Are you trusting
in Christ alone? I have nothing to bring
to the table. When I stand before God, I
will stand and say all glory to the Lord
Jesus. I am not worthy. I am not
deserving of any of this. I'm deserving
of condemnation. But you are so
gracious. You are so merciful. In the
person of Jesus Christ, you have given
me forgiveness of my sins. And I love
you for that. Even on days where I fall
short. That's the gospel message. That's
the message that changed me almost 10
years ago when I heard that for the
first time. And I learned that I can
have peace with God. That's the gospel
message. That's the message that we want
you to know. Adventists. The Adventist
church does not have that message. I'm
telling you, they they will package it
up in all sorts of flowery language, but
if you are an Adventist, you're going to
fail to enter into the true rest. You're
not going to enter into the true Sabbath
rest because that's not the gospel
message. The gospel message is not that,
oh, the door is open and now I have the
opportunity on probation to work
alongside God as a cooperator.
And if I continue doing that, I can get
to a place where I'm No, it's a
convoluted mess. It's a convoluted mess.
It's not the gospel, folks.
Next week, um TBD on on what the live
stream will be. Um we'll see, uh kind of
up in the air right now because I'm
waiting to hear back from a couple
people. So, um we'll see what it ends up
being. But either way, um thanks for
being here tonight, folks. Especially
those of you that hung out with us for
the entire three and a half hours. This
is crazy. I did not anticipate this
going this long, but always happy to
pour time into these things. So, again,
thank you for being here. As always,
until next time, God bless.
[Music]